Oh, let's go baby.
Um, everybody's tree.
Do you want to call MYK daddy?
Why?
Don't talk about my coach that way.
Hey, dude.
I visualize the coach.
Okay.
And who had the soundboard in their audio?
Who did that?
Who had the soundboard?
Why did the games who started that too?
Why is Evolve the game?
Uh, so yes, you'll be playing.
against everybody the round robin today is worth three
points per match so if your team like wins three two let's
say you'll have one the round robin nine to six if your team
somehow wins every match you can win 15-0 uh the round robin
on friday is worth five points per match so it's worth
almost double meaning if you do well today it's really good
because you can secure a lead for friday friday is worth so
much so really it's about how much you can improve from
today to friday and take that improvement all the way to
sunday and then try to win in the bracket on there on sunday
the rule will be the first team to three wins wins instead
of the normal points so it'll have the traditional format we
did last time but for the round robin we wanted everybody to
play because last time scar's team died and he played twice
out of five matches as an example uh so that was not fun so
we figured it's more fun if everybody gets to play every not
this time baby okay i'm Are we allowed to stream before you
take it?
I'm not playing right because I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
I can't focus.
There's so many voices.
There's so many voices in my head.
They're a bit loud.
Okay, I'll turn them down.
I don't know what sound guy is.
Sound guy, are you here?
Yeah.
you'll have you'll have downtime between matches because
like when you're not playing there's too many voices in my
head yeah okay i brought that at discord value you know you
have some time there everybody be playing at the same time
one thing that's important is that i can't i can't just
ignore them the same thing to make a lobby the exceptions
are people who are not playing on pc those those are the
people who like okay turn them down sorry guys i we go
straight into rules individually on but if you are not
playing on pc just let our tos know and then we can get that
figured out and you can get added by your your coach if
you're a coach i'm gonna stream real quick and show you how
to make the lobby in a really easy way so and if anybody
else wants to watch it'll probably make it easy for you um
so good yeah there's a really simple way to do it that's
that's really nice so let me uh share my screen real quick
in the copy paste thing guys this might be the old
Guys, I did unpack the PC.
I just didn't plug it in.
It's so good.
So the way this...
Oh, I missed it.
You haven't done this before.
It's when you go to player match and create the room.
Create the room and then one thing I would advise is putting
on a code in order to advance setting.
I think a code is fine.
Oh, God, please have mercy.
your private slots uh i would also recommend adding
simultaneous uh this is so that if your team wants to
practice while you play you can practice and then you click
create session oh my god he ducks he plays against kings
important thing the main match and whoever is playing next
should always be in group a please do not be like oh my
teammate just started his match i'm gonna go play on group b
or like one of these other places and then hold up the event
i will make fun of you a lot everybody will make fun of you
please don't hold up If you're going to play next.
Speaking of which, can I actually go?
Yeah, go for it.
Can you please, on record, state that I'm not over?
No!
You can either confirm or deny.
That's right, you can't do that!
Uh-huh.
I don't know.
I played him and he was Wi-Fi, so...
You got to post a picture of her fruit?
No, please, stop!
Yeah, I got the bot.
I got the bot.
take a if you take a peek at my screen here you see this
overlay here the easiest way to invite people is you click
friends click your little profile picture here and then you
go to where it says join game you just click copy link
address and when you post it in their browser and they'll
automatically join your lobby okay but what if i do this add
people in the game that's like one of the only things i can
do and i
on consoles it's just the person who makes the lobby i'm
sorry so you have to meet with them catch up this and if
anybody's on console just let the to know and they'll handle
that oh no okay another question yeah do you get that was
nice playing an honest character like dragon of or all right
so hopefully let me run at you thank you i'll be
interviewing some coaches and stuff good luck good luck
everybody thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you My man actually said that on live television.
I can't play it.
Very, very nervous.
Oh.
I came into this nigga, y'all were dudes and I was gonna run
and take it.
No!
He did it, Doug!
Okay.
What the fuck did y'all sign me up?
Nice.
I feel the same way.
Yeah, we good.
Okay.
Did everybody leave yet?
I can't tell I'm too busy in a game.
I'm so sad.
I'm like, what's going on?
I should have signed up for the first one.
Okay, look, he's just better.
I'm sorry.
Don't watch my videos then, because this chemistry will
definitely...
Because I've not processed anything in this orientation.
Get ready for the next battle.
Signifier, can you meet me?
Is everybody still in the VC?
Oh shit, everybody left!
That's a lot.
Should I lose real quick?
They're going to be scared for sure.
Okay, I'm going to lose it quick.
No, no, no, no, because they're going to play me
differently.
No, no, no, you want to keep the 13 win streak, dude?
No, I don't because they're going to play me differently.
They're like, oh, my God, I'm going to play scared, and I'm
not going to predict it.
I would rather they play me no knowledge whatsoever.
Come on, man.
I think that's just putting it all out on the table, you
know?
We'll see.
It worked for me last time.
I had a 20 win streak last slam.
I decided to throw it, so it didn't say that I had it.
Someone in the chat saying they don't save from quick match.
I don't know.
I don't know anything about it, though.
Oh shit.
Well, whatever.
I don't know anything about it.
I don't know about it So they want all the coaches to make a
lobby Yeah, you make a lobby and then I guess just post it
And then they did how big like max or they want I don't know
either bro.
I don't know either bro.
What's up, we go good shit yesterday I
all right good is a crazy thing to say about yesterday what
do you mean what do you mean adaptability bro get ready for
the next charge well don't worry about that but you did good
i saw i watched the whole thing it was stick i didn't catch
it uh bro i said you got third right yeah that's pretty good
but i'll tell you something coney yeah i mean you know this
most better the most you go for something like an off-stage
balcony punch and then and then it goes south and then it
goes to game five round yeah you were awake right three a.m
thinking about that punch yeah that's all i'm saying i feel
it it was it was a one-to-one equipment well bear has a lot
of people like me right like i'm gonna be really funny and
then spin on my back a lot and then dragon off just punches
me with the fucking skull and you're like oh okay was bad
i'm not gonna lie i saw you tweet whoops so i assume that's
what that was yeah that was also hi doki i don't think we
met hey i my fingers are not used to playing this early in
the morning that's how i'm feeling dude i'm playing tekin at
11 p.m that's too early for tekin that's
is 3 a.m vibes yeah right pecking is a night game not a
morning game that i'll i'll shake on that that's absolutely
true i'm so i'm so fucked i mean i i saw the intel report
and every i felt like everybody had tech and experience the
newbie categories except for me don't worry don't worry all
for funsies okay i'm here for the moral support guys i'm
here for the moral support you did hit an rdc on the
computer i know right now it was so hard to do i hope they
stand still for me to do the rdc
yeah the the rate of play is like way higher on this one
like even the lower ranks is like, I don't know.
People are taking this stuff seriously.
You're going to learn the King has a 70% chain throw that
probably, we'll teach you that for the second and third one,
that they probably won't know how to break.
Like in game, we should teach them that.
Get ready for the next battle.
Tony, I saw you on your little ass alt stream last night.
Yeah, what are you doing lurking in my size?
I linked them.
I linked them, dude.
My bad, brother.
I was going to get a little secret ass little ass stream.
A little ass no cam.
I need to do a gameplay side stream where my viewers go half
You can't play Tekken on the real stream Wait, I don't
understand that the link is up for the lobby I mean, I made
one I don't know if they wanted me to but you said that I
should So I did Check the stage 3 chat They asked you to,
right?
Oh, it's in the next battle chat Hopefully I did it
correctly I'm gonna play one quick match and then join after
because I'm poor seed Maybe I should just play Eddie Match 3
I promise you it'll get us through this first round Nobody
trained for Eddie right It says I need a passcode Do we have
the It's 0 0 0 9 Alright now you just stole my whole shirt
So That's the time to make it for you Come on, everybody in!
You don't have the link.
That's true, they don't know.
Oh, players welcome.
Don't pretend to be me, so I don't have to play.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I did it wrong.
I did it wrong, guys.
I made it wrong.
That's because you're 40 years old, man.
You're older than I am, dude.
Not in spirit.
I like what you said, what'd you say the other day?
It's like my nephew who is older than me.
Hold on.
I'm telling them I'm telling them I didn't make categories.
Is that okay or?
All right, I can remake it, dude.
I can remake it.
Wow, now my chat's making fun of me.
Oh my god, it's gonna be a horrible day.
The average age of this Tekken team is 46.
I think- What?
They're starving?
What?
Koki, how old are you?
What the fuck?
VTubers are young forever.
So like maybe like five?
Okay.
Then that's where.
I think three of us are older.
So I'll bring down the average.
Don't worry.
God bless.
Thank you.
That's it.
Yeah.
Together assembled.
We are a young spry 22 year old.
Oh my gosh.
We can go to bars.
Dude.
Yeah.
For the first time.
Oh my god.
We won't get carted.
It's awful for us, yeah.
Wow, they're getting right into this, huh?
Yeah, we just close to go, I guess.
Wait, you guys are in the lobby now?
Wait, I'm not in there.
Wait, I'm fucking in a quick thing.
Don't worry, I'll die soon.
I'm going to get destroyed.
My lobbies are just broken.
I don't know.
It's just not.
Okay, someone else needs to make it.
Maybe we'll let M1K do it.
Yeah, the smarter person I mean what he lost he lost maybe
he over he was overthinking maybe he was oh He's so smart
and you're so dumb true Okay, I hope I didn't I didn't say
all that the fuck does my game say online online mode
unavailable?
This is like the worst time Hold on.
I know they were doing some like maintenance stuff last
night because I was playing you guys know it was like i
never know that that happens to everyone occasionally where
it's it'll kick you off like that for some reason
mid 30s i haven't done long division in half my life so
anyone else threw up due to nerves or is that just me i say
i i know how bad I'm going to do so, I'm not nervous at all.
Wait, why is my ship not working?
I think I got to restart my PC or something.
My online mode is not working.
I know my place.
I did just now.
Get ready for the next battle.
Oh, I think I was offline on Steam for some reason.
I'll try again.
Or how do I join the lobby?
So, do you see that link in the stage three?
event that yeah post it just post that on your browser i
have a browser oh on my on my steve what i'm gonna think i
meant i was like oh my god techin has browsers i could just
post it in uh i remember we start my gc like a chrome in
techin i feel that i was like oh my god tech in chrome oh
this really is the blunt rotation group That's how he that's
how he described us now.
I know what he means.
I think we got a strong blunt rotation How do I paste this?
Guys give me a second just just paste it in the in the URL I
think oh I pieced the wrong one sorry okay we are we're
gonna get dq'd if you guys keep this up oh my god I'm trying
to figure it out how to pay I should I
who's who's up first is it it's a dokey right it's no it's
me i won't let me i'm trying i'm launching i swear i swear
to god okay i'm in i'm in we made it i did it i swear to god
it took me so long let's go i restart my pc hello matt's pc
is dying i've lost my anchor no bro no no no i just don't
know it won't connect to online the moment i launched it
says online is unavailable oh oh it's good it's good oh
everybody is everything is going wrong uh well it's fine i
gotta use the bathroom oh oh don't leave me here okay but
what if i just go eddie you do it against gummy maybe do it
do it do it do it do it do it do it do it do it just go She
won't
know what to do.
How do I stay in the right side?
What do I press?
Toggle stay.
J?
Why does it say J?
Why can't I ready up?
Click on your screen.
Maybe you're like tabbed out or something.
No?
Oh my god, this is...
This is so much.
I can't even ready.
you hit you hit the left kick button the radio hell yeah
well it's now kishin
hello why am i downloading i don't want to download oh there
you go i accidentally was on the chat screen that's why
let's go lobby created okay we did it the first hurdle is
done okay do i do it do i pull out the king the the eddie
yeah i see on a beast mode hit her with the thready the
three yeah let's see let's see if she learned how to play
against eddie that's so great
you got this well i only know one move on him so that's all
you need She started to lay out a block and bit bugged And
all your ancestors Oh, here, hit the theme song You know,
you know how to rage her Oh, no, she knows She figured it
out How?
Yo, is anyone else Streaming this?
It's like I'm unable to select it I'm streaming it Oh, yeah,
she's a better streamer than me I'm a YouTuber, if you're
real Alright, let's watch it Oh my gosh, she actually
fucking think count learn that you count there after i
fucked over i actually don't know this character you know
boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom boom three
three it's real do it for the boys of rio yeah there we go
level two but zinga what the is going on lost track of him
they drop us oh god oh no how am i supposed to do the eddies
if she juggles me nice try nice try oh you should you could
hit the three button the three button yeah the three button
yeah yeah okay i mean cody might be him cody might be oh my
god where'd her like that what we saw that we all saw the
sturdy bot it worked all the way up until what like red Rex
she's orange it'll work let's go okay okay my read for you
is you walk up and you press three oh hey okay I got it I
got it don't worry I got it get that third button on the
controller no she's blocking my head oh my god
That's not fair at all.
That's not fair!
She's hacking!
That's Harada's fault.
Let me just say, punishing a flash with a rage art is the
most next level shit ever.
Oh, wait.
Unironic.
Wait, how do I swap characters?
I don't do it my...
Oh, fuck.
My...
I'll be like, sorry, I picked the wrong character.
Raven has a one frame counter.
Sorry.
pick the wrong pick the wrong key no sorry wrong it's not as
uh wrong input the slime you gotta sit on the on the sides
brother you have um oh sorry oh me too me too my bad my bad
my bad everybody's trying to get here it's just a line is
coming in yeah bro is gonna handle this one step aside Pass
the controller.
It's okay, let me call somebody real quick.
I said it's my turn.
She's a phone of friend.
Phone of friend.
King.
Get ready for the next battle.
I won't be surprised if I do worse.
Because I have to actually think.
I don't see that happening.
It's like warming up before working out.
That's true, that's true.
It was just a warm up and now we're gonna hit PR.
Round one.
That king is so cute.
What the fuck is that?
What the fuck is she doing with that little...
Getting very dizzy.
Oh shit.
Yup, that's a duck.
Oh no, she ducks!
I can't believe it, it's like she knows she's playing
against the king.
round two you got to throw your best mids
oh my god she's so fast i think the armor runs out oh my god
she ducks everything her ass is holding down oh that's fine
though hey that's right that's right brawl pro is gonna
teach you so many good mids.
Yeah, for tomorrow.
Yeah, watch this.
This is all, we're just throwing because we all know this
one doesn't matter.
That's true.
It's too early for this for me.
Wait, my hands are definitely not warmed up.
It's too early.
That was counter hit.
Oh my god.
What?
Oh no, not the spin!
Not the spin!
Oh no!
It's not really fair though, she did have a sword, you know
what I'm saying?
That's true, that's true.
Why would you bring a sword to a fucking fistfight?
Or a baguette?
That's not fair.
That's true.
Is it all best of five?
Is it?
I think it's first of two, like last time.
It's just a round robin, so she didn't be too long.
Right, right.
You said pick the wrong character, I just saw that.
Yeah.
yo i gotta take a leak i'll be right back oh my god finally
i can chill now for like 15 minutes i don't have to do
anything yay
uh toggle i was gonna do a king mirror oh you have you're
actually wait what's this person you're playing ranked
Purple.
Same rank.
God, but you just have so many years, Kony.
That's the thing.
He has more years than me.
You gotta understand.
As old as I am, it's James Chen, bro.
Wait, this is, you're playing James Chen?
He has more years than I could dream of.
You're playing Suck my nuts, assholes, James Chen?
I'm, I'm, yes, it's that guy in the flesh.
Oh my God.
The James Chen.
Not me neither, bro.
But that's the hand we're dealt.
up so hard this one i believe in you do i pick random stage
i i don't know how stage works here i think you're supposed
to pick random okay that's what i did the entire time it's
like in the i'm about to farm another james chen clip like
the last one just just if i can make him do that again we're
good
oh my god he's a cowboy he is it's this is the it's a star
is born king i don't know which king is which which one's
our guy's the cowboy let's go cowboy oh oh my god king match
yippee let's go i'm trying to duck it
No, I'm trying to do this.
Genius block.
There we go.
Yeah, the new bash.
Hell yeah.
Oh!
Yup.
Oh my god, I can tell that you actually know what you're
doing.
Mmm, okay.
That's a nice round start.
It's a good gimmick.
I atlas have rose.
background start all the time yeah that is fucking nice
actually
boom okay you know what i should pick up king that's cool
yes yeah we should all just end up playing king in the end
the final is everyone i'll play king yeah we all just bring
out the king i'd be so down fucking go let's fucking go good
round four fight Oh, that counter hit was sick.
Boom!
Okay.
Alright, I got it, I got it, I got it.
He's always out.
You know that shit?
Whoa!
After the knee, Tony, he's always like crouch jabbing every
time.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's scared of that graduate.
Boom, hop kick.
You're right, yeah.
Yeah, knee hop kick for a free combo.
Round one.
That was supposed to be what he did, but I did the shoulder
because I didn't get the neutral.
Oh no.
Oh, I was...
That was so much damage.
Okay.
Yes.
Yee-ha!
I got it, I got it, I got it.
Round two.
Double low, that's crazy.
Oh, we gotta be a little faster, just a little bit.
Yeah, just pretend that's my king in three seconds.
days i believe all right he doesn't block this but he does
block the next one which means grab oh my god he didn't okay
whatever all right take the round okay
man three fight i keep getting that
i'm gonna try to duck but i got locked in the fucking mirror
yeah he's hit he's so scared of you yeah
so shiny he's dead god you're fucking nice with it man got
it I got it I got it I got it okay let's go let's go do not
doubt the goat I'm confident okay dude that round start
launcher I'm gonna steal that that shit was that's a really
really unsafe though you can hot kick it if you block it if
I pop that run one round at a six or nine I'm cool with it
you know what I mean like I'm like I do that on ranked every
single day of my life.
One half this hammer per rank.
Round start.
It's really strong.
I mean, it's going to crush any highs and shit, you know.
Yeah, and they won't expect it.
Because you didn't pull it out before.
Exactly.
Just for the one time.
Whoops.
Who's next?
It should be slime versus coefficient, I think.
Good is slime.
All right.
It's my turn, right?
James Chen has some words for you.
Did he just tweet this?
Suck my nuts at dude.
What the fuck?
What the fuck is his problem, man?
That's my goat.
Why did he say assholes?
I was the one that beat- what?
Can I get a link to that somewhere?
Do you not know the tweet?
If you look, if you search James Chen Suck my nuts assholes,
and go through the timeline of what- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's very beautiful.
I feel like if you just search James Chen tweet, it'll come
up.
Like, that's his legacy.
You know what I mean?
Am I ready to start?
Doki, you have to hit the right trigger.
Hit the rage art button.
Rage art button?
Oh, okay.
See, that's, I mean, oh, why am I not in the game right
here?
Coach Matthew.
Let's go.
I was like, why am I always back in the game?
Here we go.
Dan's.
guys are taking the king what happened what it was going on
wait he's taking king okay how why i didn't know about this
i'm afraid about it remember slum i had to beat an azus in
it again god of destruction on kuma so you got this it's
very doable why the is their fourth seed lower ranked than
their third seat you don't know dude because fucking sage
and also i can't spectate any of these matches watch my
stream oh no watch my stream give me the views okay give Oh,
yeah.
Yeah.
I'm not gonna lie.
I don't even know how to navigate streams on YouTube.
For real.
Wait, just press go to Yoki versus YouTube channel.
Wait, she's naked.
Stop on that.
Oh my goodness.
Wait, wait, wait.
Not allowed.
Put on some clothes, though, lady.
Oh my God.
Destroy here.
Damn.
Patient.
Nice.
A lot of blockage.
Yeah, that's a double.
Nice.
I did not prepare this matchup, I'll say it.
Round two.
Okay, we're just not showing them the stracks.
Exactly.
It's just round Robin one, we still have round Robin two.
Nice!
Oh!
It's not guaranteed.
Hellsweep's a little risky, but gets it done.
I thought the butt was guaranteed.
No.
Not after the...
It needs to be a higher wall splash.
Break the guitar.
I'm sad that her guitar is covering her ass.
I...
You're crazy?
The sad day.
At least fully commit.
Good shit.
What a hop kick, dude.
He's simply better.
Rage right here.
Mish, get the chip.
Oh!
Nah!
Haha!
Yes!
Good shit!
Oh god.
Not a rage arc, not a rage arc.
At least not immediately.
Woo!
Fight!
Good shit We take chip We get bounce Grab it Yeah, every
time
Nice She loves that string, huh?
Yeah There we go Game one, baby Dude, lots of grabs Lots of,
because like She's scared of you Not breaking them Yeah Just
keep feasting, bro You Beast.
Good shit.
Here, I gotta restart my game.
She might adapt.
Round one.
Oh, I gotta go to get a for a coach interview.
Oh, a coach interview you.
Come on.
Yeah.
All right, I'll be back.
Good shit.
Attacking that.
We have damage.
I always grab it with the health sweep.
It's a little pretty.
She didn't let go on that.
Nice.
Don't worry about it.
Don't overthink it.
Because like, I don't know if they're at that level yet.
She is starting to break grabs though.
Good shit.
Nice.
I like the idea.
Oh, that's true.
Jeez.
Alright, I'm gonna do five.
Oh, Power Crush does beat that.
She's correct there.
Nice.
Copy pressing.
Appreciate it.
That's a punish.
Did you get a control?
Did you get this?
There we go.
Good shit!
Yeah!
Big, big, big.
Just purely big.
That's all it is.
You're reading his mind!
Shit.
I like the idea.
She's giving you all the space in the world, dude.
Good break.
I just keep power crushing.
It's gonna work sometimes.
Yeah, the damage is worth it.
Good shit.
Oh my god.
I'm gonna wake up later.
It'll work.
I think I get this.
I think you get this.
You get it?
That's big.
Yeah!
That's big lead.
Oh my god.
Does this ever explain in lore or do we just still not know?
Oh man.
This is a fish that's a missile.
My fault.
Those are in the wilderness.
It's just a bear with a fish missile.
How is that launch?
What happened?
That's a weird launcher.
It doesn't even look like a counter hit.
Nice job.
I'm getting destroyed here.
It's okay.
We just want to get it close, you know?
A lot of spins.
Matterhorn?
Oh, it doesn't work, I think.
That's fair.
Sorry.
Sorry, it's just the anticipation.
I'm power crushing!
Oh, I got fucked up, man.
Oh, I had it.
It's one round.
It's all good.
I don't know what I'm doing.
She's not eating the Power Crushers anymore.
I think I gotta have a better mix-up game off of the Queen
Bear stance.
Round one.
Fight.
Sorry, I'm just so delayed.
I apologize.
Nice!
Oh, nice hit!
Good shit!
Yeah!
Two more big dog.
Round two.
Got this!
She read me there.
It's fine.
We're gonna get that back.
Ah, get out of here.
Oh, geez.
Let's focus.
Just lots of defense.
When you get in heat slime, you could grab her or something
because he's just holding back.
It's a barrel electric.
Or you could.
He's doing very good at playing outside grab range now.
Good
shit.
Oh.
Nice.
Let's fucking go!
Yay!
Round four.
Fight.
Good shit.
Oh, nice hit.
Wait for the whip here.
Move.
I don't know what she's doing to me.
See, she's showing all the cards out now.
I think I punish this.
Let's fucking go.
Round it up, baby.
Wow.
that was such a good game so you're better oh my god that
was so hard you're so much very good at yeah outside grab
range like that was really good spacing he adapted that's
always what's scary yeah not free yeah but he showed off
most dirty of his moves today well yeah we got extreme
downloads happening right now good dude let's go home i
think you got more info there than he did like straight up
if we're talking talking about like reviewing sets because
he's on his back foot the whole set like you're constantly
aggressing and pushing and he's just like in reverse you
know yeah now we just get to watch jack jesus cook yeah now
now you just sit back now we watch him win every round right
yeah right put all the pressure on on him my savior clutch
your kick bruh
Yeah, I don't really want to play.
So please win this.
I mean, I have to play anyway.
You can't do that anymore.
No, dude, that tiebreaker was so fucked up for my mental.
I've never been under so much.
Lay awake at night.
What the fuck is this Skarskin?
It's so ugly.
It's there to distract you of how ugly it is.
That's the odd future Supreme job, bro.
He's dressed like a 50-year-old YouTuber.
This is such a strange, you know what I mean?
Like a guy who's like trying to exploit the algo, you know?
Like, he's got his kids singing songs.
You break throws.
He's doing slime tutorials, you know?
Let's go.
Hey, oh.
Yeah, I should be honest with you, but you know.
But it works.
That ship is crazy.
Oh my god, what a...
Count for me, Jack.
Count for me.
I forgot how to count, bro.
Let's go!
Let's hit that one.
I thought that would work, but I guess not.
No way he doesn't do it.
Good to know.
That's all I need to know.
Nice, Lord.
Stop that nonsense, dude.
That's one of the sins.
rotate him my back oh you're chasing it down oh my god oh my
god let's go it's just got him back drop the satellite yeah
stab you in the foot drop the satellite oh he's not even
shoes I know right that's what I'm saying I swear to God
it's not me he's actually good people actually improving no
way we're supposed to see at the level they are oh my god no
we were continuing the string oh no that's all right that's
all right don't stress too long that's right we're just
giving him one you know nice fucking read on the power crush
every time I think the combo is over there's another off the
ground where did this house go That code didn't offer any
protection!
Get a helmet!
Fuck!
Shoot your gun!
The satellite.
Oh, that's hitting?
Stop sputnik!
Should I go into it with 10 frames?
Oh!
Be safe!
Yes!
Why are you doing that, bro?
Why?
Why are you doing that?
Don't listen to the code.
You don't even make Tekken content.
You can't even upload that anywhere.
He's not even creating content.
He likes that move.
Wow.
Oh.
Fuck.
One at the teeth, bro.
Oh, my God.
It never stopped.
I get kind of bored.
during these combos they're too long oh wait no this one's
kind of good actually this one's kind of hype tech is back
oh my this is wall are we going all the way in the coliseum
we get wall send him to the emperor take him to shout con
bro bro oh my god i could do a bathroom break with that
combo oh i'm uh-oh the damage first saw james jannon was
inspired wow what the what the is that that has to be a new
move that's a hot patch what if jack ate but freaky oh my
god matt okey okey Oh, shit.
Let's go.
This dude is starting to move this.
What the fuck?
Whoops.
He's trying to create a character into the match.
Pecking.
Yeah.
Yeah, that move just for him.
I hate Tekken players.
What a...
Dude, you're goaded.
That was spacing beautiful.
Yeah.
look at that he don't oh wow that's such a good move but how
long does he go matt how long do you need to hit it to the
moon surely not more okay oh no you're spacing one more mix
really one more mix guess for games scara guess for your
life for your fucking game
Let's go, dude.
Oh, hell.
That was so beautiful.
What a good round of tech.
That was such, that was insane.
What a fucking freak.
He's showing moves none of us have seen before.
Guess for the fucking game, bro.
What was that ground and pound move?
I've never seen that in tech.
The one?
The slider.
The one where you just jumped on him.
The one where you just jumped on top of him.
oh yeah you know just just uh moves that never exist i i
patched the game so i could put those moves in gotta call
the devs it was like add that yeah yeah i got the i got the
me brawler all right well god the gods came in clutch i mean
we take this easy let's be real we beat his has here coach
he's good man he's good you beat him before easily yeah what
happened where's your confidence oh all right hold on
that's his default now is it is a cape also i can't never
look like that yeah my cape king didn't have that cape oh
you know what I think it's second seven like it's a preset
it's a preset
air how good is this guy's bear I've never seen I've never
seen him it's a god of destruction I mean yeah he's not fair
yeah I think I'm like a bunch of characters yeah I can learn
some shit okay look at that Oki that's new oh Oh, wow.
I've never seen that before.
I think it's guaranteed now after the buffs.
I actually got to replay that one.
That happened to me once.
Why are they showing you everything in just round robin one?
Okay, we're getting hit by G-Clust.
Doesn't look good for Unk.
Wow, okay.
Slinky ass mare.
What the fuck?
This bear is oiled up.
Heat roll into...
What?
That was fun.
Good adaptation.
Nice.
You're not eating any of his bullshit.
Uh-oh.
Like, the Dow Bag 2 is honest there.
Nice.
Good shit.
Can I just say something?
They have Akuma on their team.
And I beat their Asusena.
Just saying.
Damn it.
You just beat him.
Yeah, he was.
Nice.
Dude, that rolled butt, whatever the fuck it is, that's
crazy.
That's a good move.
Yeah, that's the first time I'm seeing that too.
We're gonna apply that to you, Slime.
Yeah, I feel like in heat, he has even more shit now.
Yeah, and the chip damage remover, whatever the fuck they
call it.
How did Kuma do on the last bet?
Kuma got some buffs.
His hand got even more.
Damn it.
Oh.
I need to stop.
Mikey's getting his revenge.
All he had to do was use a bag.
Guaranteed.
That is crazy.
Wow.
Oh, I had never stopped.
Fight.
That's the thing about Tekken combos.
I just...
I'd just be taking 40.
You know what?
He showed his hand too early.
we know now of this jutsu we know all but then he's gonna
play fang on friday he got mad characters bro i mean that's
not his main no i'm like i means everyone for some he means
everyone monk's got a couple uh players or characters too we
can play paul for the lord here we go oh oh you can't period
that i tried to low parry like an idiot that's not low parry
like a ton no fight nice we know we know that we see it
every time we know that bounce
nice and we got the leg
holy all right end this now end this charade okay Okay,
okay.
Stop the combos!
It's as simple as that.
You just bring it back.
Just hit him.
Oh.
Damn.
Oh, that moves so good.
Oh, nice.
Let's get some life.
Let's get some life here.
Just making it close for the stream.
Oh, that was close.
Nice.
Bear's pretty good.
yeah yeah you saw how that back wall plus two i couldn't
really do anything you know what i mean it's okay we can use
this and give it to slime yeah no this is yeah i just gave
us all slime appreciate it freaking also we still won more
points three two we got it yeah we went positive on the on
the round yeah thanks for the carry thanks for the carry
guys thanks for that this is I'm the moral support guys
Yeah, is there like an intermission between rounds or do we
go straight into the next one As far as I know, I'm not
really sure Oh, I mean, I don't have the bracket
Please keep your lobby open Are we staying here?
Oh, well we would leave Because if we keep the lobby open
then whoever hosted it would stay So I think we leave no
matter what because the other guy made it Oh, I thought we
made it, okay Hold on, my chat sent me a clip of James Chen
raging against me.
I gotta go watch that.
I mean, obviously, you got an ego boost every now and then.
That sounds very fun.
Hold on.
Paste the link.
Okay, guys.
I need you guys to come in here when you're watching me with
absurdly low expectations.
We are the moral support.
We know our, my place.
Everybody knows my place here.
I am literally the moral support We have this
Oh yeah, I should be leaving the lobby Why am I still here?
Alright, this is the clip I'm just glad I'm here I'm just
glad to be here Alright, let me see this clip
Are you guys Do you guys see?
Do you guys see the clip?
He's just hitting buttons.
Bro, he was true, though.
He was spitting.
At that point, I've been him.
I was him last night against the Huarong and a Lee and a
Lars.
Like, I get it.
He's right.
Bro, he's just hitting buttons.
At that point in the set, I was like, we go shoulder into
R1.
Fuck it.
We just, just everything out all in on this.
well i shouldn't go into a match in case the lobby goes back
up well i jumped into rank just to make sure i'm warmed up
and stuff true i'm gonna continue i'm gonna do a quick match
oh okay then i have time then if you're all in a quick match
then i can't be blamed yeah we're in it we're in it together
what are you gonna do disqualifiers we cannot do that whole
team knocked out yeah whole team knocked out because we're
in quick play so i rather being quick play than the
tournament sorry guys
get ready for the next battle
all right guys i'm gonna myself i am so i know how to do
combos it's probably gonna take a little while i'm gonna go
to the bathroom i know how to do combos but i can't
implement it into the game like i know how to do that
I don't understand Why can't my fingers do this in the real
game?
I do block!
Did he stop that?
I do!
It's just that I stop blocking Because I was like, I can out
hit.
Why is the red rank playing against me?
Quick match!
Alright, I do!
I've done it!
I will show you replays of me doing it.
I swear to God!
Oh, shit, sorry.
Sometimes my hands are in the wrong position, too.
I think that's also my issue.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck?
What are you doing?
Here you go.
fuck off old man oh sure you see that coming oh he like does
that shit and it scares me
there we go
no stop i'm just stuck new
stop don't duck he ducked oh my god it's like he plays this
game more than me bro i have fucking two days of more
experience on this fucking game if you lose a set from me
you're fucking terrible if you lose one round off of me
you're so bad imagine being red rink and losing at one round
from a fucking person who has three days of experience
This play before
You're so fucking bad Imagine being ranked and losing that
Oh wait, what the fuck Stop staying on the ground and get up
Welcome 90, she's got the play
Okay, goodbye I'll never touch you again What?
Dude, I like Grappa.
There.
You like that Grappa?
Is that what you mean?
Oh.
Oh god.
Please let me do this move, please!
Okay.
She's so...
It's a quick match!
Alright.
It's fine.
He's red rank.
He's... It's fine!
He's red rank!
Just...
The fact that he lost one round to me when I had three days
of Tekken.
That's the sad part.
I need to like...
Okay, there's like this move that I can never get correct.
Like the kick, like the low kick right here.
Please!
The one, two kick.
Why can't I do it?
Please.
Oh, there you go.
This move.
I keep fucking it up.
The two.
Please.
Why can't you do this kick?
There you go.
That's why.
And then it's supposed to be like this and then not that.
It's the timing.
I'm not good at timing, apparently.
Get ready for the next battle.
Exactly.
These people.
Okay, the thing is, these people have much longer
techniques.
hours and days of doing combos in me and I'm coming in with
three days here any round I take is like a win for me with
the amount of tech experience I have whoa what the fuck okay
what she expected oh okay you tell this person is a team
against King Bilal.
There you go, because I know you like to duck, so...
Oh god.
Wi-Fi warriors?
See on Wi-Fi or my own Wi-Fi?
Or is it my PC?
We'll find... we'll figure it out here.
Yay!
What the fuck?
Sometimes I don't do the...
Jump the...
The low punch.
No, not low punch.
The low kick.
Oh, it's because my fingers were on the wrong area.
Please.
Thank you.
That's all I care.
Please.
Same.
Doki, please, I know.
I...
I, like, tell that to myself every day.
Please!
Oh my god!
I got a perfect the one time my combos actually work.
The one time my fingers actually work for me.
Do you think she's gonna duck?
Okay, she's just gonna beat me up.
Ducky, please.
Okay.
Guys, look.
We know my place.
You guys, you think I can improve, like, improve 10 speeds
in the next three days?
We'll find out.
Okay, let's play against what I don't care people are like
people keep telling me to discriminate against the Wi-Fi
players And reject all Wi-Fi players, but I was like I
really don't care
I don't care
Wait do we join?
Wait, which stage are we Oh shit All right Don't worry
Nobody said anything!
How is I supposed to know where...
Oh shit, I'm not focused.
I was looking at my discord.
Alright, here we go.
Oh my god, he dashed the ducks.
Who would have thought?
Coach, I got a question for you.
Yeah, what's up, bro?
You want a match right now?
Yeah.
Let me know when you're out.
I...
I want your insight on something real quick.
Round two.
Please, I'm a believer.
I think you came in thinking that I'm gonna go far this is
why I am the moral support it's nice that somebody believes
in me you know wait you actually block Lowe's bro what the
fuck what's wrong with you do you think he blocked this no
this is literally my one move if all else fails if all else
fails I I have that one move.
Now imagine losing a fucking Rana off of me.
What are you gonna do?
Do I do this?
Hey.
Do I do this again?
Alright, no.
He fucking learned.
Okay.
But what if I do it again?
He does not learn.
I told you, that's like the only thing I know how to do.
Oh,
God.
Okay.
Do you think he's gonna learn again?
Nope.
Alright, let's try again.
Do you think he learned?
Oh, he did.
He learned because he's trying to get closer now.
He's not giving me space anymore.
There's no...
No way she would do it again, right?
But there was a way.
You think he learned?
No.
Do you think he learned, guys?
I don't know.
He doesn't learn!
I told you!
I told you, that's, like, literally the only thing I know!
Well, not the only thing, but one of the things that I
consistently do is just, like...
You think you finally learned?
Guys, I don't think you learned.
That's so sad.
That's the thing is I can't do that for real on people
though Because everybody else trained for like 20 plus hours
Not the one and done Yeah I do that to everybody I do that
to all the players They never do Get ready for the next
battle Yeah it's a bit tough That was so toxic.
I was just like, I'm just like, bro, I'm clearly you can
like beat the shit out of me.
I'm not going to fucking give you another game.
Like, I'm just trying to fucking have fun.
Okay, I did not mean to jump there.
That was an accident.
Guys, I think this guy would learn, though.
This guy might learn.
Guys.
Whoa.
You think this guy would learn, though?
We'll figure it out.
Yeah.
there we go okay give me space give me space so i can see if
you learn oh he does see why can't that other guy do it
because he because you're not yellow
as the attorney ended no we're just waiting for the next
round to start he didn't need to learn because like he he
actually is a good good enough okay i know some people
That's good enough for me.
That's a good rank for me.
With me as a player.
That's a lot.
Yeah, this guy.
See, this guy knows?
Like, why can't the other guy do that?
I don't know why I keep trying to do it.
I was just like, maybe it'll be different, you know?
Okay.
Well, this is scary.
This guy is It was just that guy's first time playing King.
Bro, he's yellow ranked.
There's no way that that guy was the first time he played.
Oh, God.
He's faster.
He's so much faster.
No!
Oh, my God.
I'm goodbye.
Oh, goodbye.
It was...
This is his first game.
As long as you have time, you hit up your coach.
It sucks.
Because, like, oh my gosh.
Okay, so, like, hey, Brawlbro and I were talking.
Like, I think, like, the day before yesterday.
And then we were...
Because, like, I was like, what the fuck?
Because, like, it was supposed to be Connor, right?
Connor was supposed to be in my seed.
And then Connor got replaced by another player.
That's played Tekken before.
I was like...
Wait, what the fuck?
Like, she plays a lot of Tekken.
And I was like, wait a minute.
Sejab told me this is for newbies only.
What the...
What am I doing here?
I was just like, what?
I'm just like, oh my God, I'm going to get absolutely
destroyed.
oh hey that this king knows what he's doing bro he's like
this he's like stars because he knows i want to do that
thing that that only i can do please the only other yeah but
like gumi when she gets into a game she plays a lot of hours
of that Okay, I should actually play this game, though.
Sorry, I was having a conversation, fellow King player.
I have the stream.
I think it was alright.
Boomi's been fucking grinding.
You guys behind your backs, and that's about it.
She's actually been grinding!
I had other obligations!
You had a question or something before I got pulled into
the...
Yeah, let's say, hold on.
Let's say I want to get...
Actually, I don't want to rank so I can do it because we
can't get them all.
Oh my god, does this...
Hold on.
Oh my, sometimes my fucking down doesn't register and that
makes me sad.
Oh, wait, you should block that.
You're a king player.
You block this?
Oh, he does.
Let's say I want to go That's so many obligate.
This was the only week I was free.
I was fully free.
Oh my god.
Everyone cried it so much Whatever you're doing do not
bother around start.
Holy shit.
Oh, it's because I'm doing monitor capture That's probably
what it is Maybe you want do you want to see do you want to
try?
Yes, like my only hours to run Tekken was like it starts at
like around eight to ten like around 8 to 10 p.m.
is when I start grinding Tekken the last three days.
Well, wait, the first day, the first day I grinded Tekken.
The first day I had a lot of time because it was like right
after announcing a WrestleTuber.
Then I went straight into it.
And then I grinded and then I started and then I grinded, I
think like the day after my day starts for grinding because
I have to do my other obligations first, like my other work
hours stuff first.
10 p.m.
That's when I start.
But then everybody else starts way earlier.
72?
You can, okay, see how much it is if you just back 3 into
the Jaguar 5.
But like, like, for now, now I have a lot of time.
Now I have a lot of time.
But like, everybody is now like 20 hours.
Like, I heard like SK has like 90 hours plus when I started.
I don't care about optimizing it, yeah.
Let's just pause.
That's way No, I meant like, no, I didn't mean like 8 to 10.
I mean, I start at either 8 o'clock or 10 p.m.
And then I would play until 4 in the morning.
I would play until 4 in the morning.
I would start at like 8 to 7 or 7 to 10 p.m.
And then I'd grind until 4 a.m.
But then like, by the time I started grinding, SK had
fucking 90 hours.
And like, I think she has like 130 plus hours now.
And here I am.
Use this move And I was looking at the intel report I was
looking at the intel report And then all the other Nubies
were like close to Red Rank already I was like what the fuck
I was just like And some Nubies have had Tech experience
before And Rank I was like what am I doing here?
What am I doing here?
I thought Nubies meant As a Nubie Nubie Oh that as well i i
went in thinking newbie meant actually newbie what's this on
the damage but newbies were not i didn't realize newbies
have not met newbie i'll pop that i'm not cute okay i can't
believe it got it all right cool i'm trying you think she
knows how to no she doesn't give me space for this i got
sent to the ones i I did.
Maybe I can fit in one match.
I did.
I got sent to the fucking Gulag.
Oh, he made the lucky right now.
Oh my god.
I don't get the one.
Oh wait, that was not what I wanted to do.
I guess tomorrow or in two days, I'll just scream way
earlier.
Yeah, like the average was much higher.
But I'm having fun though.
Learning Tekken for...
Wait, why am I playing against a red?
Every single round went game five, by the way.
So everything is like dead even right now.
Alright, it's fine.
She's red.
I'm having fun though, but it's like, I'm just like, what
the fuck am I doing here?
You know, if you guys do end up burying me this time around,
I'm totally cool with that.
I guess, because I did a lot of work last time.
You only played a couple sets.
That's how I'm feeling, but I'm still trying, right?
I'm trying.
That man was 5-0, bro.
I mean, you lose.
I only lost to one person.
What did you do?
You know, you beat one guy.
right the tiebreaker dude i mean you want one set though you
know damn he ain't fucking called out i don't know
when is our next round starting it started so you can enter
the oh nice yeah if you go up this uh what what stage one
all right stage one say i learned how to do it for real this
time all right i'm getting my ass kicked let's go it's 10
hour dokey versus 100 10 hour sk oh okay i was telling them
about the sk thing yeah 10 hour session
yeah i am not catching up to the sk there's not enough hours
in the day for me to catch up wait no that you you can radio
up can't you okay yeah they said you guys are good to go
maybe i can ask sk to give me like one free hit dm her dm
her right now can i have can i have one free hit yeah just
so okay you can ready you can ready i only have 10 hours
slime you gotta you gotta do the little toggle stay thingy
and fd sig has to do it too there you go yay time to three
escape escape please just let me have one hit that's all i
want no we're getting several hits okay true true true true
true i'm gonna like dream of that too many moves a combo
even yeah oh my god a comp okay maybe you're asking a bit to
a combo actually whoa a combo i don't think i've seen that
before
all right that's right i gotta get into the mental of
winning of one hit in the combo and you could just also just
use it as a learning experience too that's true that's true
it's only round robin one i'm going to give them like a
false sense of security so when the finals hit are you still
in the game dokey yeah i'm like loading up we're in now i
think we all got dropped from the special literally every
single wait what oh thank god okay well i pulled up s case
stream Yeah, I'm on the stream now.
You wouldn't believe it.
I got three hits!
Oh my god!
What?
Hold on.
Oh my god.
Why did you guys drop when I got hit?
I got a KO!
Alright, now it's all downhill.
Guys, I can't believe it!
We can't believe the one time you guys got locked out.
Bro.
Hell.
Why am I so unlucky?
Let's get it.
Let's ship.
Ship damage.
Oh, no.
Okay.
That's all right.
me maybe play with me for real okay goodbye you know more
grabs than i do like you're popping shit i haven't seen oh
my god i don't even know what i'm doing meet that jk i know
that what i'm doing that look kind of fun though that's
right it's all about the fun i got my one hit just keep
grabbing i think you win if you just grab like a madman
that's true that's true oh my god you're right okay They
learned.
Yeah, they learned.
They learned.
They learned down on the controller.
Wait?
What the fuck?
I think now is when we use the RDC technique.
You can do it.
I bet it'll work.
True.
Oh,
no.
Now I'm gonna, in a long ass combo.
Oh no!
How is she so fast?
Nice.
Okay.
Oh.
No, I'm not fast enough.
I didn't feel one plus two after.
I just like go for it.
Why is she so fast?
Yeah, rain is cheap.
Is this why everybody plays her?
Oh.
It's all right.
I got my two rounds.
Now I'm happy.
That was impressive.
You almost had lock in.
Lock in and this is actually yours.
I believe so hard.
Okay.
Alright.
At least somebody believes in me.
Hey, I believe.
But do you believe in me in your heart though?
Or is it just word?
Yes.
No, I believe.
What you just did.
I think if you get your offense off, you're good.
Just run your stuff Oh my god Please Please escape Please I
thought you were going gentle on me Escape please let me
have a move
Oh come on Nice mix with that shit Oh god Hey remember your
fight or flight Yeah Oh,
SK like knows that I want to grab her.
She like stays on the ground.
I can't believe she knows King players like to grab.
Yeah, honestly, who taught her this?
I know, it's actually crazy.
Like 100 hours.
It must be like all the King players she fought.
Forbidden knowledge.
Okay.
Oh, I thought it was gonna land.
Me too.
Rain is cheap.
There's a rain here, so it's just rain.
Rain is cheap, that's not.
Oh my god, she ducked!
Stop ducking!
It's being taller!
Goodbye.
I had a good one set.
Oh, that's a good block.
Oh.
Nice try.
It's alright.
I had my moment in the beginning.
I grabbed two rounds off a 110 hour SK.
Yeah.
Two rounds?
Not bad.
I think once we just teach you mids, like, to counteract the
duck, it's easy.
I think once you play 100 more hours, you're gonna be good.
Yeah, I just need 100 more hours.
I can see that.
Or Friday.
100 more hours of game before Friday.
can make that work it's so easy who needs sleep it's all
about the techin oh i gotta join back in that lobby why i
fucking no get me out of here
guys i can't believe though when they want i can't believe
it they got spectator on the rounds i actually do well
What is my luck?
I was like, oh, thank God they DC'd.
They don't have to watch this.
All right.
Oh, I thought it was Raidits.
Is it Catlin?
Thank fucking God.
Slime has Raidits.
Oh, it's okay.
Got you.
Wait, really?
I thought, oh, wait.
I thought it was fun.
Dude, we ran into Raidits yesterday.
We have data.
Oh, yeah.
We can tell you some shit.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hey.
i'm so down i did it because i thought i thought i was
fighting raiders i was ready to go get ready for the next
battle you got this all right i do not know azusena but we
learn on the fly i believe
good side stuff
all right we're just backing up a lot this is grabs oh we're
doing that until they do they're probably getting active
coaching about it though Yeah.
Nice block, Kony.
How am I delayed?
Three points!
Yeah, last night with the rank.
Three points, distributor.
Ooh.
We're just cleaning up Azusena Nation here.
What the fuck was that?
Oh my, that was a good break.
Oh.
Oh, I'm like five seconds behind you guys.
Is that a wall coach?
Bro, don't do that, bro.
I think it might be.
I think that might be a combo.
Oh my God.
Chat, I'll be able to do that in three days.
Stop breaking ones, bro.
I hope they coach is talking.
It's dress.
Oh, now it's ones.
Okay, we only break ones.
Might just be mashing the one-one move.
That move right there.
Yeah, because it's doing the counter hit sound.
So she's just messing with one.
Oh, such a smart decision from a smart player named Kony.
Oh, my God.
Who is he?
Knee into any other grab that isn't one.
And I mean, you take it easy.
3-0 as well.
Yeah, yeah.
Let's just keep going twos.
Yeah, just do two.
one yeah oh what wait what quit that's fine i wanted to
change my skin anyway all right watch this it's a mental
game we're gonna we're gonna change our skin to the bane
skin from last night and see if raided's nose that's him
that's him yeah i actually so slime i was holding on to last
night i was i went last round with raided's and i was like
all right i'll lose which i'm fine with but if i spammed
back three i think i would have beat him because like he's
just he's just mashing so i don't know how good bears uh uh
power crushes are it's pretty good so don't like spam it
obviously but like hold it you know what i mean acceptable
yeah yeah all right we go find me he does a three hit over
and over it's like a kick then a punch and then uh another
punch it's like back four two one oh never mind i am playing
raid it's on a Oh, okay.
Okay.
Got it.
It's just confusing.
Never mind.
Avoid everything.
Crashing this boat.
He's realizing.
With no survivors!
Oh!
Oh my, wait.
She changed her outfit too!
Oh.
Yeah, every time.
She doesn't know she's minus.
Oh, love that.
Oh, nice.
Round two.
Oh.
Remember that?
Yes, I know.
Yep.
This will not work in two days.
True.
But then we go level two.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, exactly.
But level two is so fake though.
And then you go to brand destroy.
And then you go to level three.
one we start doing it again that's true yeah the nl was
right man what a dog that was old right good low she keeps
going high there okay i'm just gonna keep popping though i
mean like i just luck it in you know like oh my god my point
just give me my point if i did the shoulder i win that fuck
when it when she hits you with the running three two just
get up and hold back he'll probably do another okay round
four fight shoulder i got shoulder is too hard maybe one day
okay listen next time you know tomorrow you're literally
gonna be five hours i was gonna say i'm doing shoulder
drills tomorrow seriously like i i just if i do that i'm
good like just imagine what if you lost because you didn't
hit that confirm and that will motivate you i know i And
that will motivate you.
You'll never ever ever Good shit.
Let's go fucking solid Tony wins fucking easy good wins good
shit good shit.
Okay Get in there boo boo bear.
What are you fighting against?
Oh, this guy the thing way You just beat a titan king kishin
kishin cousins ain't shit i do i will say i've played this
character very little i'll be kissing your mom that's what
i'm saying bro not my mom that's what i dm to all these guys
all right we can go and ready run it uh let's go good luck
brother
you know guys do you guys believe with me that i'll learn a
lot more tech moves in two days do you guys believe in two
days i'm gonna improve so much i didn't actually care ever
rose he's just delicately holding a rose
okay he knows he knows he analyzed your play style
oh wow
Oh?
Just never let him get up.
Damn it.
After you get hit by the splits, just hold back.
He's two plus.
Okay.
Round two.
Tio.
What the fuck?
I don't know.
It's definitely a matchup gap.
Wow, nice pairing.
Oh.
Oh,
nice.
Watch the rage arc.
Nice.
He's good.
You can block.
Oh, no, you can't.
No, this guy's good.
Oh.
Yeah, he's playing proper Yeah, he's a real tech player
Counter pick him to a theater Which stage?
Yeah, guess what bro?
I dress up like I dress up with a fucking mustache and a
revolver Oh, smooth Kuma Round one Fight
Oh, what a break.
Yeah.
Oh.
I think I got him.
Oh, that kills?
I got him.
Yeah.
No.
Dude, I'm gonna lose my mind.
That's so close.
I hate this fucking character.
I tried to go for the lane.
He's smart.
I could have a better mix up off that.
What the fuck is that?
That's to stop you from mashing.
Even though what he did was unsafe.
I didn't even do that.
So he's confused too.
Nice.
You knew.
Oh, nice!
Nice!
Nice, good shit.
Little touches.
So close.
Good shit.
I had a comeback.
Nice, dude.
He's good.
So he's showing all his cards now.
We know how he plays now.
Get the fuck up.
Why can't I fucking get up, dude?
Oh.
Round four.
Fight.
I was blocking low too.
I did a one.
Yeah, I saw it.
You knew.
What a miserable character to play against.
Yeah, thanks.
It was just nothing.
That's a good-ass player, though.
He's just a good player.
Yeah, he knows a matchup.
We'll work on.
That's all.
Yeah, we'll go over that whole matchup, dude.
Oh, you're right, though.
That did look miserable.
especially for bear in particular like i don't know when
he's gonna i just don't it's it's a guy's playing eddie i
know for a fact he's playing eddie hold on i gotta get out
of here not this old ass this 60 year old man what okay we
just wanted brawl pro to be able to have a match as well put
them in a home all right i'm gonna try here we go some
obvious stuff then i will let you know i don't want to
interrupt your game though unless it's obvious yeah yeah
yeah i mean you just do whatever you need to whatever you
feel like is like he obviously is not picking up on this
i've told you what the did i say zafina my ass zafina my ass
were you prepped for zafina no Oh, I'm not prepped for
either character.
He's about to play his theme song.
Round one.
Fight.
Oh my god.
Fuck, I didn't get it.
You don't need prepped.
Look at you.
Cyborg Eddie is so funny.
It's like trying.
What a punch.
Getty would be like a Metal Gear boss, right?
Yeah, right.
Dancing cat, like...
That's your name.
Fight!
Escapade!
Okay, that's fair.
I thought you said I get that 4-2 there!
You can.
I tried.
Gross dancing.
It feels kind of laggy, and I've never complained about lag
before, isn't it?
Round 3.
Secretly on Wi-Fi?
There's a foul on Wi-Fi.
holding up the snouts that's what don't he had the wire
connection going to a wireless router
he just unplugged the ethernet cable is it after the dive
where he tries to take his plus 8 where I can die for it too
after down 4 it's just a fake out move I'll show you when he
does it I'll mention it
high slash oh Why is it lagging?
I don't know.
Maybe it's because he's on console.
I swear, dude.
Okay.
He's in the Elvenio like shit though.
Oh yeah, it's airborne shit.
Oh.
Nice.
Good shit!
Nice aggression, man.
I need a labbit.
Why is this a ledge?
Is it like it's slow-mo for you guys?
Yeah, it is.
Yeah, it is a little, yeah.
Ooh.
All right, lock in, lock in.
Oops, I didn't mean to do that.
Yeah, it does look a little...
It is, yeah.
That's strange.
Bro bursted out the lag switch.
It feels chunky.
I don't like it.
So won't bit the Ethernet cable.
Whoops, I messed up one of them.
Nice.
Launch him.
Oh, nice.
That combo makes me so anxious because it looks like a shit
hit.
I did not mean to throw out of there.
His throw breaks are pretty weak though.
Good shit.
I'm sputnik.
I'm okay with this.
You do kind of deserve it.
Oh, are you still okay with it?
Are you still okay?
What?
It's like an Elden Ring boss.
Why did that?
Shrack.
Bro, they keep more guns.
Nice.
Right in the penis.
It's just, did this controller DC?
I don't know.
We take those.
This is such a weird fucking...
Yeah, you did.
I'm taking it.
I'm taking it, bro!
There's no fair fight attacking!
Oh, wait, no!
He's up!
He's like...
No!
He plugged it back in!
He plugged it in!
mouse a keyboard yeah that's definitely switch gameplay
there it's like chunky dude he's the whatever you know what
i'm down back winning
oh launch oh you can launch that move that low that but it's
hard to tell bro yeah i'm sorry nice
Nice grab.
That was good.
Bro's got kicks.
There's probably one more.
You're crazy.
That was a crazy move to start.
Yeah.
Doki knows too.
Yeah, if I knew that, he then it's bad.
Just watch the sweep.
Yeah, he's He's sweeping like crazy dude.
Just sit and wait.
Cash out.
Why the fuck?
I don't know Eddie.
I don't get it.
I don't know.
Eddie, I don't know Eddie.
He's just spinning around.
I don't know Eddie.
I literally don't know Eddie.
Fucking ready to rip.
He should have a dizzy meter.
Dude, I've never seen this before.
He should have a dizzy meter and if it fills up, he vomits.
Somebody stop this man.
Nobody can do this for real.
No human alive.
What a launch.
A dizzy meter, bro, that's incredible.
Just bring back all the stamina bar.
If it fills, he has a 360 frame vomiting animation.
Bring back the stamina bar at this point as well.
Yeah, he's tired.
He's tired.
He needs some rest.
He breathes like Mario when he has red health.
It's like, whoo, whoo, whoo.
I've been lied to by my coach.
Dude, what?
You guys have gone wrong.
No, I've been like that.
It's our coach's fault.
You're dead.
He's been paid off by Big FDX.
Quick, unplug his controller.
damage possible from the rage art no he was airborne oh you
still see how much of it okay that's good what oh what watch
the rage art
let's focus oh baby let's go oh my god he's the strongest
what the fuck i'm talking about if you join the slam you
would Whoa!
What?
He didn't need a prep for him!
Also GG's, that was really fun FDI.
Jesus with the Neuralink.
Amazing.
That's right.
He didn't even need a fucking prepare!
Whoo!
What almost...
We're labin' the Eddie Madgeo, bro.
That was me fighting without any Eddie knowledge.
Who is this?
Dude, I think if you just block low a lot.
Wait, guys.
Who is this guy?
who is this i think that's very funny is that not i thought
this is fdx's team that's uh that's fdx the tech and king
reina don't you know he's working on it he's working on the
reina is he bringing the reina is he fucking with you this
guy be justin wonk so i'm gonna need you to lock in he's
good he's good there's a lot of people in our lobby no
that's him who is the reina
lobbied who the fuck was that wait did somebody leave the
coders so there's a lot of people joining it that's like the
ghost of marvel you gotta play me yeah dude oh my god i love
that guy that's one of the rooms that's i've never seen five
fgc clips all time nobody stopped him he got all the way up
to chris g all the way up because so many people watch that
they're like how did how did nobody stop and people who are
like in esports production are like oh i get it like they
said yeah right
fd is molding there's so many people in the lobby who leaked
it i would
he didn't make a public one so i mean he didn't make a
private lobby so i think
when i fucked it up at least i made it private you know what
i mean
I was like, I don't, these are too many names.
Oh, wait, he's asleep for two elbows.
Oh, this is a concussion for sure.
This actually damages him into the next round.
I have your head on the pillar.
Ouch.
Oh.
What a break.
Oh, those slowest jumps.
I didn't know that low kick was mid.
That's crazy.
Round three.
Fight.
I mean, this character won Evo, so it's not your fault.
You're just playing off meta, you know?
Like, like, like, look at this.
Some bullshit arena.
Why is she magic?
All right.
We downloaded.
Ice powers?
I'm just giving you a free round, right?
Oh.
Oh my god.
I know how to do that move.
Damn.
Nice.
We pop that.
Awesome, Rage Rider.
Nice.
Break her back, bro.
Snap her.
Yeah, Bane him.
Take this.
No.
The fucking game play.
We're on the same stage.
she'll hit that that's mental you're welcome brawl pro
speedx is like i can't believe you do that i just can't i
just can't believe you he's raging nice
oh name bam bam bop bop don't worry i'll be able to do that
too bounce and die oh no
Oh That was crazy That's generally the closest thing to the
mango that you can get in this game The like literal perfect
optimal back turn punish that's legacy as fuck Oh
Yeah, bro is laying down.
Damn.
Counter hit giant swing dealer.
Does he know to tech?
I don't think so.
Imagine.
It's a god of destruction thing.
Like, do you protect that in swing?
Oh my god.
Break the stage so that you can do that move you've been
yelling at me to do.
Good grab.
Ain't no way he's not breaking the ones
Nice, you know, love that no what let's hit one B She
doesn't know how to break it Oh You hear the chunk on that?
Yeah Keep doing it.
She doesn't learn Boom boom spin around Look at the ball
coach back Oh, break the siege!
Oh, hell no!
What the?
Oh my god!
It's still going!
I can do the bathroom break!
Oh, stop.
How dare you?
Oh, wow.
I hate that game.
No revenge.
Damn.
Oh, those are fake.
That's launch.
bro oh okay nice i guess oh send him into one touch is that
fully ko no uh it scales down a lot because she's in the air
right it's one mix it just doesn't scale well uh string
combos huge break timer they're both gaming wait it out no
don't wait it out damn it no Oh.
Nice.
Very close.
Now you're in my house.
Ping should be able to run backwards.
I got you for three minutes.
Three minutes.
Pro-pro is ready.
Nice.
What a call.
Good shit.
Oh, Campbell, she ducked it.
She's dead.
Hella dead.
Nice!
Never rage arts.
Oh, nice.
Hey, what if this is guaranteed?
What if this is guaranteed?
Oh, okay.
What if they call them Freaky King?
Freaky King.
What if they call it Freaky Age?
Oh, what a win.
He ducked!
Actually, ducked.
It's fine.
he's playing with his food break man yeah he was gaming that
was a fucking fun to walk let's go coach good shit I'll be
able to do that in three days guys hell yeah dude that one
round where you guys just 80% did each other back and forth
was yeah that was sick non-stop combo was forever good dude
that was the hard team by the way they won uh four one and
now we beat them what three two i think that was the hardest
team in the in the whole tournament man i lost i lost the
last coach match so i'm i'm glad i had to bring it back for
the team okay that was fun as well good set that's fun yeah
i'll remember the time i took two rounds off escape Rubby.
Man, yeah, this is fun.
I missed the first stage and slam.
You like that shit?
It's stressful, but it's fun, man.
Do we just like, we got to wait for the next stage now.
Back to quick play.
Yeah, actually, let me pop in a ring.
Because we got a while.
All right, guys, it's back to quick play.
All right.
Maybe this time.
Guys, I swear I would land one combo today.
That's not on the bot.
I swear to God.
No, oh, wait, I got the map I wanted.
I learned so much.
What do you mean?
Look, okay, watch this.
Okay, neutral and then boom!
Now let's see if I can do that on a real person.
Yo, are we right into it?
Oh, we're waiting.
They still being our next round, but I think we're still
waiting.
Look, I'll be able to do that on a real person soon.
Oh, I gotta fight my roommate, Josh.
Are you guys gonna offline it or not?
No, we should play online because we can both get left.
Okay.
and uh oh that's probably less complicated to like respect
it wait who's what rank is this person round one oh 12 whoa
sorry bro
oh god i forget oh it's albert please please oh god please i
don't know your moves
Wait, do I get that?
Oh, I do.
I get that out.
No!
Goodbye.
Is that your?
Who's your?
How many more rounds?
I think we have...
I think we're fighting...
We're fighting every team.
And there's six teams in total.
So, uh...
Watch this.
Sorry.
This is literally my favorite move.
Oh god, oh god, please, I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry, I'll never do that again.
I'm so sorry.
JK, I'm not sorry.
Do not duck!
Watch this.
That's literally the only thing I know how to do.
JK, I also know...
Oh wait, I know how to do this.
But do you think she learned?
No, they never learn.
That's why I like doing it.
Because they don't learn.
There you go.
They never learn.
Nope.
Okay, I messed that up though.
They never expect it.
Why don't they... I don't understand.
They should expect it.
Like, it's such a good move.
Oh, alright.
Fine.
Bye.
See, they never learn!
Oh, wait, she did the thing to me.
Yay!
I beat a vanquisher!
Yippee!
I don't get anything because it was quick, play this is a
winning I like the sea goodbye I'm a one and done person I'm
pressing buttons one day I'll be able to do this in game one
day don't worry bye at a time the second round hit round
robin two hits i'll be able to do that in game a one and
done
this evil monkey she will live without defeat forever i bet
you that person is practicing techin for like fucking weeks
and i roll up there and ruin her day i hope this person
knows i'm streaming and finds out i've only been playing
techin for like for like, uh, three days.
That's all I want.
Can she dodge this?
No.
Oh, she can!
But can she dodge this?
Oh!
Okay, I should stop fucking around.
Please let me up.
I'm sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I was fucking around.
They never expect it twice.
Okay, but does she expect again?
Oh, wait, she did.
Okay, but do you think she'll expect it again?
Oh, she just swings, yes.
Okay, I should stop trolling now.
For real.
Okay, for real this time.
Let's do that move, Doki.
Oh, man.
I want to do this move that my coach keeps telling me to do,
but I can never pull it off.
in a real fucking game.
Because it's so difficult.
Please.
I'm trying.
I really want to do the move that my coach wanted me to do.
Please.
I can block.
It's just that like I get impatient.
All right.
Watch me block.
Okay.
You guys think I can't block.
Watch this.
Wait, this person has 13 wins in a row.
This guy's actually a fucking bullying noobs.
See?
Look at that!
I told you!
I told you I knew how to block!
Nobody will believe me ever!
Watch this.
See?
I told you.
I can block moves.
Oh.
Do I hit these?
Yeah, I do.
I told you!
do that in the actual look this is not the tournament this
is just a round robin this is this is just a round robin
there's love bow lobby is up okay i need to lose real fast i
gotta finish this match but then i'll try yeah me too i'll
be in in one second oh my god me too but i
Look, chat, lads.
It's okay.
I'm purposely losing.
I muted the wrong thing.
Guys, I'm purposely losing, guys.
Guys, you don't understand.
He just ducks and launches me?
No way.
Can I keep doing this?
That sucks.
And I'm going to leave and he's going to be furious.
I feel really bad.
Okay.
This guy's good.
and I'm just one and donening him after I win.
Yeah.
He did promo off me, though, so...
Okay.
Please, I need to lose.
Dude, I'm sorry.
Thank God.
Okay.
I fought a drag who was very good and cleaned me up first
round.
And then I beat him second game up by left because we had to
get in this lobby.
Oh, I feel bad.
Okay.
All right.
Thank God.
Okay.
If that guy comes in here, I'm going to apologize.
All right.
now to join.
Where the fuck is it?
Oh, there you go.
Oh, my God.
Which guy?
He is savvy.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
He was very good.
He slapped me first round.
And second round, I beat him and I had to leave.
So, I just got my win and then left.
He thinks you ran.
Yeah, he thinks I'm... I feel bad, bro.
My bad.
Oh, there's a passcode.
Excellent leak.
Listen.
Nobody's coming in here, right?
We're good.
If that guy comes in here, his name was germ i think hey if
you're watching
maybe his twitch won't be the same as his steam name oh god
gold king versus oh god i believe i'm going in there with
confidence and you saw coney's match and my match just yeah
i absorbed that i observed all of that Exactly.
Maybe you guys should change your name to Doki as well.
Free publicity.
Okay.
I see.
All right.
Here we go.
Mission survive.
What the fuck?
No.
Why?
I forgot to put my costume on.
Oh, it's okay.
that's probably a big deal for like youtubers right now my
costume i'm default dan default dan okay restart restart
freaking esam and sk the es people man with so many hours on
the game es spanish spanish folks
Please let me get up.
I hate martial law.
I'm sorry I hit you, just let me get up.
Cook this man.
Martial law hates rich people, you know, so.
I'm gonna do that.
Oh god.
Can I get up in time?
No.
This kill is on.
Wow.
Wait, I'm alive.
Okay.
It was nice being alive for a second.
Wait, I'm lost.
Are we stage two?
Wait, what?
Yeah, we are.
We started the game.
Yeah, Duggy's in her match.
Yeah, I'm really in my match right now.
And martial law is unfortunately cooking.
Oh my god.
he is definitely cooking okay he's all doable he's like
three ranks above me uh i think it's more
it's okay i could catch up oh that's right i told you i
could catch up i could get to red rank in less hours i
believe actually we'll do that you know what yeah you know
I'm gonna do it.
I'm giving them a false sense of security in round robin 1
and I'm gonna roll up in red rank round robin 2.
Wait, I'm alive.
He's gonna slide again.
We got a download from the first round.
Like slime is doing, we gotta do that.
That's it.
In the second set, I'll remember that.
It's because I'm not in my costume.
I'm getting distracted.
Yeah, exactly.
I mean, it's a real thing.
King's boots are so shiny.
I just noticed.
Oh my god.
They have some nerd ESAM.
8,000 hours.
Ooh, some of us have lives.
Yeah, some of us have other stuff to do.
But it's okay.
delayed that.
The best if this video game is like so important for you,
that's fine.
Okay.
You must really want to go to Evo.
I can pay for my own ticket.
Yeah.
All of us already want a trip.
Doki is a multi-billionaire.
Yeah.
Fuck again.
The shit is nothing to me, man.
I don't know what I'm doing anymore.
No, don't make me laugh!
Oh my god, please.
Please, my coach made me laugh.
Did that bounce?
Let's go.
That's true.
I bet nobody's laughing over there.
That should sound like a funeral.
Like, let's be real here.
What are the real stories?
because we got a trip to evo no fun over there doki
billionaire multi-millionaire yeah i'm having so easy we got
three content creators like one is a good game like
overwatch you know this is all about making content oh that
was clean oh shit i got it content let's go the only person
that probably couldn't afford it was brawl pro but like yeah
what the the go-out
I got a run!
I got a run off of bread!
Kill it for fun!
Oh shit, that was my bad.
Oosh!
Oops.
My hands always go on to the wrong position sometimes.
Nice call out.
Yeah.
Yes!
See, I'm learning!
I had a feeling because he kept ducking!
He's a duck lord, yeah.
Learning experience right here.
See?
I knew I can learn!
Break his arm!
He can't afford insurance!
That's true!
He is poor!
Wait a minute.
Mix up?
No!
Nice try.
Be honest, Doki, did you know the mix up there?
Did you know, like, what to do after the...
Yeah!
Because whenever I do that throw, I don't know what to do.
I'm like, uh-oh.
We're both guessing.
We're both hitting a button on the controller.
Something would work.
There's a lot.
Whenever King does that, it's crazy.
You'll be molded into a killer.
Exactly.
Look, look at what a couple of hours I can do.
Imagine what happens if I get like 40 more hours.
You will absolutely make it.
I can, I believe.
With your belief, I believe.
And hey, you can just buy the tickets.
You can buy your own.
I want the mental warfare.
Imagine losing a round to a yellow.
Bro!
Someone said ASM is stone-faced right now, so they weren't
having a good time.
Really?
No way, man!
Joshi's bed silent and all he cares about is vibes.
Sure I go, I'm locking in.
I totally, we're winning like the content wars.
That's where all the views are at.
That's what it's all about.
Like we didn't even win Last Land, did we?
but everyone remember no exactly remember that's true that's
what everybody talks about yeah that's right yeah we're
coming in with more content it's it's the truth i sorry i
need to get the out of here my bad
yeah oh you gotta swap out oh all good give me a sec
actually i think it's gonna kick you out i thought they were
gonna swap they can swap me uh matt like automatically
get ready for the next battle
round one oh raiders
that that third hit you can duck yeah i remember just just
gotta get hot kick after the second yeah no i tried to back
up yeah that's my fault i tried to back up and i tried to do
a hop back did that kick here okay round two fight dragon of
moisturize challenge impossible
okay i'm about to say this guy doesn't know i think he knows
guys don't break your win streak funny after you get hit
with that down too you can challenge it with while standing
four He's minus one after that.
The spinny low he's doing, just mash for it.
It's a mix up, but I don't think he's going to play that mix
up.
Oh my God, counter hit grabs.
He's mashing, bro.
Bro, he's just like me.
Dude, he's actually just mashing.
Wait, really?
Yeah.
It's just buttons.
Oh!
Wait, mash him back!
yeah it's just fucking buttons dude okay he loves it he
loves the low off of uh yeah that's that down too that
killed you round four dude fight
oh it's just like magical man oh
my god i tried to create space whoa just look at the damage
here oh oh god i thought he was against oh bring his arm got
it there's no way let's go baby nice job broken earlier
let's go ray i mean sorry coney i got i got brain rot like
for real i got brain rot i got brain rot i have no
disrespect i'm so sorry that was on purpose it was for
content reasons oh my god oh my god Ray, no!
Got it.
Alright, I got it.
Let's go, Cody!
I got it, I got it.
Perfect!
He gets run over.
He gets run over in the alley kicks.
Yeah, dude, I was sending it.
Fuck it.
If he can't mash, he doesn't win.
Fight!
That's the wall standing for ya.
Yes, sir.
Yeah, I'll kill you.
He always goes low.
That's not gonna work on day two, but fuck it.
Yeah.
We'll run drills on that.
No biggie.
Oh, nice.
Did you know how to get up?
I know that move.
Yeah.
I knew it was low, but I didn't know how to beat it.
Like, I could just hop that and follow up.
No.
Fight.
Oh, nice, one, two.
Dude, he's just getting that low.
It's just, I can't power crush it.
I'm not doing anything about it, but he's doing it every
time.
He, like, downloaded you.
There you go.
No, he's going to take care of it.
He's fine.
Oh, God.
Like, I know what you want, dude.
I know what this fucking guy wants.
It's just, I have to learn how to pee to it.
It's annoying.
fight
i gotta stop doing that oh never mind okay why does he keep
getting hit with it some half the time it makes no sense to
me and he's probably just guessing that like a mix-up
instead of reaction
ah oh yeah okay oh okay all right it's just so much it's
just mashing dude it's just i don't do it that low so many
times i know i know what to do i'm just trying to hop kick
it you got it you got it yeah just i know what try and match
score instead if you can mentally adapt but not a big deal
yeah fight nice as we talked about thank you oh no i'll be
able to do that one day it's the same fucking thing every
time oh my god my controller died okay oh it's fine wake up
wake up insane dude quick plug in them mouse and keys it was
alley kick it was tally kick oh my god ah i could have
kicked after running through hop kick home
Nice.
Hop kick.
No, I see it.
Good combo.
We're on the wall.
Take him to the other side.
Let's go.
Yes!
Yo, he might be dead.
Oh, one more hit.
Yeah!
Good job.
Round three.
Just making it close for content.
Fight.
I'm just trying to get space.
Oh, ducked.
Nice.
Ah, fuck, man.
We got to try to stay aggressive.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
More than him.
Good crap.
Okay, I didn't know what that was, so I didn't do anything
about it.
I was like, what the fuck is this?
It's okay.
It's hard to react to.
that's a yeah i will absolutely be this guy if i just learn
this dragon because like i keep trying to i know it's the
low every time i just keep trying to hop kick it i just need
practice yeah yeah and then that three hit string too it
keeps counter hitting you you could just duck and launch
them for it yeah i'll be ready also the low can't kill you
like most lows in this game unless they're giant reactable
ones they're just meant to annoy you and get you to duck so
like you're getting really frustrated about the low existing
it's like early on it's a it's okay to eat eat it right it's
like keeping composure sure yeah while getting a load is
more important also if you're calling it out that hard low
parry mix up oh true i didn't even think of that you're
right just slap him in the head about if you know if you
want to avoid the whole like trying to think of wall
standing for or launch probably parry you know i can beat
that guy i'll beat that guy i believe i know you can cloney
all right you got this you got you got this dude grudge
match grudge match oh god he's probably got dude he's he's
scary i'm ready bro look at that rig you got this i don't
mean to disrespect him i didn't hide i just hide my barrier
we played a bunch yesterday so it's like it's definitely a
meta matchup of like yeah there's we're gonna see layers
when we watch this we're gonna see layers i thought he was
on a list why do you swap uh he thought she was lame uh she
is he's right he's 100 right face real Appreciate it.
Get ready for the next battle.
Ribon.
We're in the same house.
See what the ping is.
17.
I'm going to say 17.
Wow.
Round one.
Fight.
You can launch this Watson in one, by the way.
Oh.
Oh, it's minus 14.
Definitely playing different.
He's not doing Orbital.
That's fine.
You're learning now.
Fuck it.
So then we do the grabs and stuff and running one plus two
mixes.
And down back four also.
Oh.
Nice.
Cool.
Okay.
Nice.
Good shit.
Oh, yeah!
Let's go!
He's going to start orgling now because he thinks I'm going
to do that.
Oh my god, the mind gains.
Nice breaks.
Oh my god, he just wasted.
Come on, Bear Joe!
Yo!
Oh!
Okay, better than nothing.
Let's get it.
The touch damage.
Nice.
Brace.
Oh, wow.
I mean, that's literally layers.
That's like you take a guy for five years and you just know
what he's going to do.
Final round.
Fight.
Oh, he's looking for it.
Yes, sir.
I guess you're over to all.
Oh, there it is.
Finally pull it out round three.
Last round.
That's what destroys me.
Shit.
what a counter hit oh
you're still alive oh you did a lot of damage with your
sleep though so i mean he earns it all back but i think he's
not gaining he's not gonna run up to me he runs up to me oh
oh oh very close game oh that's so close real close real
close you win but you adapted you know so you already know
what to do yeah I think he's alright that's fine I think
he's just stronger at adapting no dude when you adapted it
went way better yeah he was one he was 2-0 you came back
yeah he got this bro
nice that's a long he's he's a jealousy dude
I don't blame you for trinkets in the air.
I thought it worked.
Yeah, I would have done it too.
Yeah, I don't blame you.
Fuck.
Yeah.
That bait.
Nice.
Nice bait, dude.
Good shit.
Oh, nice bait, dude.
Oh, nice.
Yep, yep.
Yep.
i'm sorry oh my yeah get out of here pal get out of here 13
frames respected okay
he can't get over it not yet at least
nice yo oh
what a no both dude the down back two see you're adapting
nice are you bombing
hell yeah i'm not trying to do that
what a g club that's a bear player one day i'll be just as
patient nice i i could i could feel the layers from here oh
All right, my game just caught up.
Good shit.
By the way, Konyo, you didn't know he won that set.
Thank you.
Yep, good to know.
Mine's chugging a bit.
Round one.
Remember that's spectating when you spectated Super Mad?
That was so funny.
He went SSJ.
Dragon Ball Z.
Bro is blockade.
Oh, my God.
He lost half his barbed chip.
Fucking orbital, man.
Okay, hit the wall here.
oh nice nice block nice job
nice nice he's not adapting anymore dude i fucking low
parried bro i'm so fucking mad oh my god the input was there
to fight
when there's one grab
always reason I'm not going to do health wave anymore rest
of the game
oh god it's alright I think he's good that's the problem the
problem is that he thinks he's good I know Tony says the
same sentiment True, true.
There it is.
See, what even was that?
Like, that just hit me.
Unplug his internet right now.
Nice.
Dude, I...
I react pressed.
Aww.
Nice try, bro.
Nice try, nice, yeah.
It's okay.
Game three.
We got stuff to learn.
He's so fucking not good at this game.
You're not gonna walk in your room right now.
I don't know who this guy is, but fuck that man.
Oh god.
That's Tekken.
It's alright, he showed all his cards.
It's okay.
He knows no more moves.
Oh.
Yeah, we'll go.
Dude, I can go over this right after the round robin, man.
yeah i would i would love to yeah it's gotta suck losing to
the roommate you know what i mean go to his room right now
and be like i heard him pop off too i can literally hear him
pop off wow i mean damn what are you doing oh it's just
gross make him pay for rent for this month get ready for the
next battle box box is hell of a rhythm so you know we'll
see I could get out random tier.
Genuinely.
Or I can get 7 billion damage for no reason.
And then Rita got crushed and then it would be okay.
Don't worry about it.
Rita!
I forgot that like I played this game.
You can do that!
That is something you can do, yeah.
Oh my god!
That was crazy.
Just tilt him right now.
Blast him!
Oh, oh, oh.
That was funnest, I'm crazy.
Oh, my God.
Jack is fucking brutal, dude.
Bro, is he even gonna touch him?
He's gonna think about this in the next round.
Any amount of money.
Stay on the ground.
You've gotta be fucking kidding.
Holy shit.
That was good.
This was like me against Boxbox yesterday.
That's why he said this out.
God, dude.
It was really fast.
Yeah, that was like 20 seconds.
I mean, I might still fuck up.
I might still fuck up, you know?
No, you already fucked with his mental.
Boxbox has a pretty good mental, though.
He's crying.
Check your stream.
is he crying right now is he oh i'm gently weeping did a
definite teammates this chat's telling him he did a great
job he's in his own echo chamber right now oh oh drop the
set yep yeah you just we're just here to make him feel
better that was crazy eight i can look up that was nuts he's
also not wearing the nest outfit this is tournament awesome
Go.
Oh, no.
This guy's definitely a center.
Oh, nice.
No breaks.
Send him to heaven.
Why did you do this, bitch?
What the fuck?
What the fuck is this, dude?
You guys beefing?
This is its chain.
What?
I like this guy.
The James Chen!
Suck my nuts!
He did download you!
This is it!
It's like a Twitter combo.
And you can't read it because it's all in Korean.
He's like a Japanese Greninja.
Like this shit looks unbeatable.
Oh my god!
The forbidden shit.
The forbidden move.
Oh my god, he actually downloaded it.
That was a good step, yeah.
Cool combo, box box, nice 40%.
However, we're keeping it close here.
Content, content.
Oh my god, her health.
You are greedy, my friend.
Punish her, it's a sin.
Perfect.
the rotation that has to be the quickest round ever greed is
a sin greed is a sin true there's a speed run pb character
put that on speedrun.com right now that was fast box box of
worlds okay speed running box box well what an insane
character oh that first round was crazy that 10 years ahead
time read that was crazy someone said that was like four
perfect rounds oh my god box box any percent no glitches i'm
more of a fan of the glitches category that character looks
like a fucking glitch dude that that's an eagle like some of
that damage is insane i mean four perfect ground holy shit
get his ass coach wait slime death is he gonna beat up his
mermaid
we're talking about how you might be beating out Josh man
because he died oh no no I was talking about how to beat him
next time yeah in game in game in game you gotta fight
another freaky i am oh my gosh i'll be able to do that combo
one day he even did the rotation what oh what what is this
oh nice
Oh Good engagement wall Geez Round three Fight
Whoa We love hop kick in this house.
Nice Boom and boom and maybe one No, maybe a little bit more
he does that we go off Take him to the wall but oh my
goodness gracious bro's ass unc oh my god get a spoon
oh man he's kind of moving now wait god bro he broke the
wall he kind of woke up yeah come giant swing oh oh shit the
comeback he said get me out of here let me out time for the
other wall oh one guess guess for game no oh no oh my guys i
almost had it i had a missed input
yeah yeah we're just getting close
false insecurity
oh nice
nice nice
that's a freaky brian nice dude that first that last round
he did 50 percent on game start that's crazy yeah as you
guys he has the same costume as the other one
the amount of times i've been hit by that we're trying to
fight bro bro dude
nice wait you could do that what the fuck you can flip him
yeah i saw that but that hit
Yeah, I was like, what?
That's a move?
He was done on that side.
Bro works at five, guys.
Holy shit, man.
Like a pancake.
The fact that even Cody didn't know you can flip.
I've never seen that.
He did no damage.
Can you stop comboing, man?
Dude, that's crazy.
He's his character, man.
He's just touching death.
rotate him again it's hard to deal with brian when he gets
walled here he's gonna get walled yeah deal with brian at
the wall it's a really tough stage i think yeah this stage
is fucking scrub lord stage
oh oh
yeah even though
huge nice oh That's serious.
That's so broken.
Good shit.
Hmm.
And his combos.
Well, at least he doesn't get bounce.
He never charges that one.
Oh my god, he didn't breathe.
Oops.
There's a bug on the floor.
yeah like break him hate spiders
Oh, it's so scary ain't no way coaches are doing spring
kicks Oh my god, and again
Wait those kicks
Nice Oh!
Wave dash back?
That kind stuff.
F smash?
Cracked.
He's fucking cracked.
F smash.
Fun set.
Good shit.
Let's get off this stage, bro!
Let me out of this way.
Wait, were we on stream?
No, we were not.
We were not.
We were on stream?
We were last round.
I think stage one is stream.
We're stage one.
Nice.
The roll.
Waldemort?
I'll be able to do that one day.
Good shit.
Damn it.
Wow, that's nuts.
Giant is relentless.
Round two.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
All
right, we got a wall.
Nice!
Oh my god!
Good shit!
Where'd Blood's face go?
Send him to the hospital!
I know they're crazy under that mask.
He ain't got no teeth.
Good shit.
Oh nice!
Oh!
Oh my goodness.
That's a nice punish.
Love that.
I love that.
I love that when it happens in the game.
Oh, oh, no.
I mean shit, I mean shit happens, whatever.
No recovery of life.
That's alive, you know.
It's getting a little close.
Oh.
Oh my- I fucked up.
Okay, it's okay.
Okay.
Let's fucking go!
Oh my god, I'm gonna die.
He gave you two chances!
Oh, Brian, two times!
He parried it twice and let him know he could.
Today I will go low again.
It was to make a statement.
Surely they won't predict another low.
They'll never learn.
Nice.
The dokey!
The dokey, I love that.
Learnings for chumps.
Guess what?
your life licky brian nice game bro god bless on that stage
too he's talented let's go bp dude bro pro team is on top
right now if you if you just didn't get hit by those kicks
he did the little jump it would have been wait because like
he would just pop that at start you know yeah i can explain
too when i'm you know when he ragearded me at the wall and i
did like a back two randomly yeah it's uh it's snap back on
my stick so if i fling forward forward it'll go the opposite
sure and then the same with right there at the shining
wizard at the end i flicked it forward three times really
fast and then it flicked back and reset neutral and i'm like
oh my god so i have to be careful that's all oh that was
crazy though that second low parry that was so crazy chip
bro yeah i can't believe you got two of them i thought you
fucked up i was like shit we guys i think he wants to fight
me again i'm gonna fight broxbox again i don't know he
literally joined the lobby as i was checkmarked because i
was like oh i'm gonna fight tone but tone dude rate it to
james chat i gotta watch these sets dude i gotta there's so
much content to watch once we're fucking done okay get ready
for the next battle time to watch the rematch i guess this
is a rematch maybe the salty run back salty run back i like
that i like i like how boxbox the fucking gamer about it
yeah he's he's a he's a hardcore gamer dude Fight!
He's like, let's go!
Where are they streaming it?
Boxbox is streaming?
Fucking bitch!
I'm sorry.
I hate this guy.
The rage are...
Rage are...
I'm gonna use the bathroom real quick while you watch this
rematches the century.
He is evil.
He is special evil with it.
Nice block.
Fight!
I can't believe Josh popped in.
Yeah, he did.
It was a close stat, you know?
I feel like he was sandbagging when I was watching.
I don't know, man.
What was up with that?
He finished all the combos.
You drop them sometimes, though, slime.
You're in the BNBs.
And also, like, let's say you do the hop kick, you'll do one
back to one in the hunting bear stance.
You could do two.
Back to one, back to one, then the bear stance.
Right, right.
Okay.
If I want to- Yeah, you have to- We shouldn't in the first
place.
Yeah.
We're on stage three now.
Oh,
they already made the lobby?
Yeah, we're set.
Yeah, lobby.
Okay.
Matt and then take a game off Unk?
Oh, again.
Okay, I'm back.
Yeah, maybe.
My devil chain?
He beat my devil chain while we were coaching.
Oh no, but get out of my way.
I don't know if I want to fight me again.
Okay.
All right.
Sorry, I got to finish this set.
I don't know what's going on.
He wants to fight.
Let's do it.
Lobby's up.
Oh, Lobby's up?
Four kicks.
Yeah, it's up.
That's so fast.
Yeah, they're just moving through it.
We got two more, two more sets.
that's the fastest one yet what the hell i'm like stuck in a
loading screen
i'm in
are you playing the flooring i can't even get into the lobby
unfortunately yeah mine was a little miles with that arizona
host let's see i'll just join again see if it
Any fellow yellows in the team?
Maybe I will restart my game.
Maybe some bronzes.
Not everybody's here, so we have lots of time.
Yeah.
So, Doki, how's your first Sage Jam Slam so far?
I think it's pretty fun.
It's been pretty fun so far.
Yeah, learning.
I haven't hit my ceiling yet.
I've been all these other newbies.
ready close to the ceiling you're definitely not at your
ceiling yeah on
the challenge it says that we lost the myk so i'm trying to
get that swapped my god oh there's like a wrong score or
yeah it says mk beat us three two oh uh rigged oh i see
somebody bribed the coaches get ready for the next battle if
that's how we if that's what they want shit i'll wire
something up wire some money real quick to say gem give 50
subs remember slime when you didn't fill out the stupid evo
form i'm very wealthy don't worry about me 40 flight wait 40
dollars wait wait what That's interesting.
I like the various fear flights.
You're like double digits.
What are you?
What are you thinking?
$40.
And SageM is like, no, bro, I got you.
And it's like, I got you.
Jesus, his neck.
He should be dead.
On the street.
Oh, fuck.
Why do I never focus on these?
Oh, I forgot about the hotel.
How do you, for you?
Where are you going to sleep?
I don't know, bro.
I'll figure it out.
Oh!
Yay!
Wait, you can cook this guy.
I told you!
I haven't hit my ceiling yet!
All I can do is up!
Wait?
Oh!
All I can go is up!
They've hit their ceiling!
I haven't!
Give him whip.
Look at him flail around.
My bro is slowly advancing.
He's just slowly advancing.
That was like a Simpsons.
scene or at least if you get hit it's your fault literally
jaguar mills unironically you seem to is you a duck oh wait
i messed that up jk will you duck this time let's do it so
slow though we'll work on that though
okay i'll swear i'll get better oh my god oh my god she's
kicking the shit yeah i told you if you hit three leg drops
the set is over like freaky Okay No, I keep messing that up,
but it's okay.
He's dead.
Wait, this thing is freaky, dude.
When will you learn?
You never learn, just like me.
Oh, never mind.
Never mind, guys.
Okay, watch.
No!
He's learning, guys.
I don't understand.
Guys, I don't understand.
How is he learning?
Kick him in the head again.
Yeah!
Yes!
That's fucking right.
Now I'm going to stab you.
Oh, my God.
That's fucking right.
What else?
His legs are broken.
You can't afford your hospital bill.
That's Joe Rogan yelling arm bar.
Arm bar.
You know what?
I'll take that.
I take those.
You'll take those.
too oh waiter waiter one more please oh he did okay but will
he expect this okay but will he expect this oh my god this
dude doubles your prowess by the way i know that's what i'm
saying how you're melting him bro it's like the mental game
he knows too he's like how am i fight or flight This is it!
Oh my god!
What are you doing?
I'll be mad, bro!
I'll be mad!
Dude, it's so good.
It was straight in front of everyone at Times Square.
I know, he's so embarrassed!
Like, how are you doing?
How are you letting me do this to you?
What the fuck?
Okay, now he's actually mad.
Oh, no.
He has to be pissed.
Onto the street.
Bro, why are you not learning?
Why are you not learning?
Oh, my fucking learning.
Doki Bird can be anyone who doesn't learn.
Yeah.
That's it.
That's really it.
If you don't learn, I can take advantage of it.
He literally stood up like R1.
I've never seen that.
He was on the ground.
ground please i've done this move 20 times i think i think
we do a couple back dreams not oh my god he's talking no
hello yeah he's definitely that's it wait that's that's it
oh is that it i won the game let's go let's go nice job i
got one Oh, that's what the fuck I'm talking about.
Good shit.
I'd like to dedicate this win to my coach, Kony.
Okay.
Coach Kony?
Yeah, you're welcome.
You're welcome.
Hey, more alley kicks next time.
Yeah, thanks, Kony.
Well, I just got cooked for no...
But what about the fight or flight?
Something you can teach BP.
Something you can teach.
look at that he must be so mad yeah oh i'd be furious let's
pull up his stream let's confirm these theories a little
hypothetical wait who am i fighting what are you fighting i
thought i was fighting uh is this am i fighting a yoshi i
thought i think i'm fighting zentrea yeah no no no it's just
another public ass lobby for some reason oh i see i'm a
subscriber They should just have me make these.
I know I fucked up the first one.
That's mad annoying.
All right, let's get it.
Someone kicked this guy.
Dude, that Brawlbroke clip where someone's calling you
Hollywood and you're like, I don't fucking, I'm not fucking
Hollywood.
He thinks he's better than everyone.
I was like, no, I don't.
And there's like this big pause and you're like, except Ali,
I'm way better than him.
But that's it.
Dude, it's so funny.
Just sitting on it for now.
No reason.
I live for the Bro pro, Ali fucking beef.
Dude, so fucking fucking hate that guy, man.
I just saw him the other day.
He's like, what are you saying fuck me for?
Oh god.
I hope I'm in that man's head right now.
Oh, he's thinking about that L.
He's gonna train hard for it.
He's like, I got killed by a yellow?
Round one.
Fight.
June Kazama.
Oh my God.
We got the Luigi thing too.
It's John Cena.
Yeah, because I'm daring you!
Oh my goodness!
Luigi, Cody, if I can see it.
Super Luigi.
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I called him Luigi too during the first time.
He did that, he did that.
I don't listen to hip hop much, so I don't know.
Yeah, I don't know.
This is how I know you're fucking funny as shit.
John, my favorite character from Nintendo, John Luigi.
Oh my, always wake up.
Oh my Lord.
Wake up buttons running through your your gut right now.
Round three.
Wake up buttons, huh?
Fight.
Okay.
That's fucking right.
Oh my, yo, that shoulder would have been perfect, but two
times today.
Okay, nice.
Bro, does Zen learn?
Oh
Yeah, because that's low mid Okay
The fuck is that Wow Oh Nice Funny might just be my goat
dude Oh my goodness I got it I got it I'm saying bro Do it
again Do it again it's just always wake-ups man watching
cancans round one fight oh we're never ducking and no more
wake-up balls right i said no wake up that's enough you
gotta learn to do it again i remember i learned it i learned
it mid-match it's forever ingrained what stop what the fuck
now she's rotationing good boy nice
no way we're still getting up with buttons like i just
assume it's over but like you don't learn i got three of
those two very new i got three oh my god oh my god you're
Good.
This really is John Cena.
Yeah.
Oh, wow.
Wait, that was clean from him.
Oh, yeah, that's sidestep.
Oh, look at you.
Oh, that dog!
Look at my big baby boy.
That's him!
It's on my end.
It's okay, you just...
You just want to keep it close.
We're gonna wake up with buttons.
Oh, shit.
I haven't done that yet.
It's my turn.
It's still my turn.
Cooked.
Simply cooked.
No lawyer.
That's our coach.
Yeah, whatever.
It's cool.
Yeah, don't be too.
Yeah, don't be just do that.
You too, bro, bro.
Yeah, you too, bro, bro.
You were there, too.
I hope you guys learned something.
Oh my god, I learned, I'm taking notes right now.
Worshiata, a very scary player.
You got this, dude.
Yeah, it's...
He beat his head.
I think it's Alma time.
They play hella, like, I don't know how to describe it, but
solid.
Okay.
Real Tekken.
They play, yeah, they play Real Tekken, quote unquote.
So, all right, if you want to chase him out.
Up to you.
That's my own.
Wait, what does Real Tekken mean?
He doesn't do any, like, weirdo moves.
He just kind of, you know, pokes.
every now and then you know oh is it so he's there to tilt
you oh is this is this sifter's team shift here was it
really that funny when i said sifter you just started
giggling bro dude i was not the only one laughing man okay
but but still i think you started it i'm like that was silly
yeah let's feel this out i'm not gonna be throwing out
willy-nilly stuff
Round one.
Fight.
Step.
Ooh, you can't be eating that.
You're a kitchen.
Cushing Cousins.
That's a very common...
And like that string?
Don't want two kicks.
Over two on that.
Oh, big.
Is this game being streamed or...
know uh you can do my stream i got it i mean i'm streaming
it oh no i meant like i have not received that okay you know
whatever bro you have enough subs man i don't even stream
i'm a youtuber let me grow i'm a youtuber too so you know
how i feel let's go tech is not even your main content i got
a sleepy tag i'm gonna take a nap real quick
what is happening there he's just poking and it's so weird
because he's so basic but also so creepy wait that's a 1
plus 2 2 that's a 2 it's a 2 oh my god he has a main
character buff it's not fair that's okay we cook nice nice
you can wall combo here but but too you can still could have
done the but and shit That's why we get the reset get more
dubs.
Oh He doesn't know how to get up again He doesn't know how
to get up.
He doesn't know how to get up.
Hello, Perry.
Okay Final round.
Oh, come on You do Oh, wow nice grab
Oh god
He's a fucking character.
I've never seen this kick that I'm getting hit with in my
whole fucking life ever yeah so that's like a badass like
across the map counter hit launcher
like the third move what is that like he's hitting me with
two hits and then that kick oh you mean the the downward
kick no that kick that just like counter hits me oh that's a
move on its own it's his forward four yeah it's a solo move
it's just a counter hit launcher full screen
you can with punish it but it's a really good move yeah
it just pushes you off i'm tired oh what a time
it's okay you got the advantage see what oh
Round two, fight!
Slap it!
Slap it.
Yeah!
Nice running.
Oh nice!
Oh my god, nom!
Oh!
Nice!
Holy shit!
Round two!
shit
Come on
He's only grabbing with the two grab yeah
Fight What a oh
Nice Why am I getting fucking turned around?
I don't know what to do you you press one post dude?
That's why he does that You hit up?
Yeah, oh my god really good rage.
Wow Maybe you can heat and then cancel it and then fish.
I don't know but the wall is right there I don't know.
Yeah, I'll give it a shot.
I'll try, I'll try.
Okay.
Pete.
Yes, sir.
Yours comes out first.
No.
Oh.
That's safe?
Yeah, that's a really solid character.
That's close.
Oh my god, I hate that fucking character so much.
So can you download him for the next round, Robin?
We got hella info on this guy.
Jin, Jin is so weird.
Cause like, he's not like spamming, like Warring or
whatever, but he still feels so like, I don't know.
It's just moves.
I don't know how to.
Oh, yeah, he's good.
He has really good buttons for sure.
Yeah.
100%.
Oh, man.
Whose team is this?
Oh, this is Miles.
This team, okay.
I've never fought this guy in my life.
I've never even seen him very fast.
I have no data on this guy.
Please leave.
You said that from FD.
Yeah, you said that for Eddie.
Yeah, but this guy's a lot of us.
That whole time.
This one's a little different.
Yeah.
Yeah, I can hear you.
No, we heard you.
We heard you.
Yeah, sorry, sorry, sorry.
who came up with jack jesus was it just uh someone's chat i
think it was day jam i have no idea might have been a chat
might have been why did he even say that you don't i don't
know he literally said they call him jack jesus who's day
yeah who is that well now they do he he implanted the yeah
i've never thought this guy will try have you fought alissa
a little bit i kind of know We'll see.
What the hell?
Is that boss?
Oh my.
She can't see.
What the heck?
Wait, no, I'm behind!
Oh, what the fuck?
That's an SCP.
She's scary.
Oh my god, what's going on with my game?
My spectator bugged so hard, I went Zoom.
Yeah, it's so goofy when that happens.
Volcano.
Nice.
Oh, nice!
Oh, you see how he got up wrong there?
Yeah, that's the information.
And you were scared!
He got up wrong!
Oh my gosh.
Oh, he's getting up wrong.
He's getting looped with it.
Wake up directly, bro!
Whoops, whoops, whoops, whoops, whoops, whoops, whoops,
chill.
Alright, bro.
I love this guy here.
So fun.
Nice.
Oh, bound.
Yo, there's a side wall maybe.
Oh, that sidestep.
Yeah, we have to recognize sidewall and you know what I
mean.
Yeah, I figured.
What?
Sports it?
Yeah, get her out of that.
I can't believe that works.
That always works.
They'll never learn.
This team doesn't learn.
No, one plus two.
One plus two.
Oh.
Nice.
Drop the satellite.
Punished?
Ah, sorry.
I didn't know it was punishable.
Oh, it hits still.
Oh, is that?
Oh, my God.
Now you know why I was confused.
Yeah.
I can tell that Kony is way behind.
I'm very behind.
You know, I think it's the state.
I got to restart this PC.
You're like drop the satellite and then we're like four
seconds ahead of you.
I'm watching like a John Woofield.
Oh, you get your HP back.
I know, right?
It's a hard counter now.
Genuinely.
It's good to armor, Alyssa.
I forgot about that.
Oh, fuck.
This is close, man.
I don't know Alyssa.
Damn, this guy's pretty good.
He hit confirmed that too.
That was nice.
A lot of chip, too.
oh oh no she downloaded you oh my okay nice it's a lot of hp
there fuck okay understood i can uh fix this you win yeah
it's okay you can is that hop kick is that hop kick how
punishable 13 minus 13 okay yeah so you a shoulder or you
could do your two three thing you just can't forward one one
i think okay okay is it is it zero to one or one to one zero
zero one okay yeah yeah you can one one yeah one one also
fight no she gets up wrong oh yeah it's hard to do
i think i need a two jab more i'm gonna try to see if it
works Oh my lord, the HP, that's insane.
Oh my god, she's so dead!
You get so much health back.
That's absurd.
Nice step.
Yeah, that was good.
Oh shit, that's launch, huh?
You have to stay ducking, yes.
You have to stay ducking.
Low high.
It jails though.
What if I duck the, or I get hit by the high, what happens?
Is it like, you know, the frames on it?
I don't know the frames, but it's like neutral-ish.
Oh, do you hit that?
Yeah!
Yeah, it is neutral.
It is neutral, but it does chip damage.
I don't know what to do here.
He's gonna do something random as shit.
I'm gonna get it.
You can run up and block.
Punish.
Nice!
Punish!
Oh my god!
We take that.
Take it.
We love that.
Yeah, yeah, your head, your head!
Oh my god.
Oh, break it.
Yes!
Oh my god, don't let her get up!
This character is fucking insane.
I know, right?
What the fuck is blood doing?
Oh my god.
This is unbelievable.
You downloaded her back.
Every time Jack is on screen, the screen is shaking.
I'm getting dizzy.
Oh my god.
The dizzy meter.
Eddie's dizzy meter.
Ed She was so stupid.
Matt, you can duck her one-on-one.
Oh my.
Oh.
Fuck.
It's all right.
Wait, what an annoying character?
Oh wow, the counter hit you dead.
Oh my gosh, nice.
Nice.
First win.
Good shit.
Oh.
What the fuck was that roll, man?
What is this?
Oh, okay, man.
That's what you do!
That's what you do to people!
Look what you're doing!
Look at you!
You hit that?
Yeah!
That's free, right?
She can't get upstairs.
What's the mix?
He might rage out if you run up into nothing.
Maybe run up into nothing.
And then the...
Heat dash mix.
What a fuck.
That was cute.
You got cute with it.
I like that.
Oh, fuck.
I think he's going to go low at the walls and then I'm just
going to try and get the down four one plus two maybe.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, wow.
Well, we didn't guess right there.
We all died.
Yeah.
Team every.
Nice.
Okay.
Round four.
Pretty good.
Fight.
Fuck!
Oh, I can't believe- No way!
Oh my gosh, no!
She should die there.
Yeah, right?
The head's on.
That's her head.
Come on, man!
Oh my god.
Okay, I'll try.
Alright.
It's like a self-destruct.
Oh No blue spark Oh It's okay Oh what a back step
Nice Nice Shit Oh nice
That's right There he goes Let's fucking go Let's fucking go
He's the anchor man dude a trump card definitely emuting is
not a good idea during these sets because dude that i i
think it's good like the down the how you dug that string
and launched them for it that was good i mean it made sense
it's low high good bro good okay bravo's gotta bring it back
bring back all the king wins why do i have to play again
yeah keep the points coach oh get us more points yeah yeah
no no it's it's 3-1 right thanks chat yeah but if he loses
this he's like the weakest king player out of all of us it
is all the other kings won the match yeah that's interesting
didn't think of it like that some coach she's good bro what
do you want me to do i want you to get stunned by coney and
dokey yeah come on that's your job You can't just break the
king streak.
This is a lot of added pressure that I don't need here.
We're prepping you for the finals!
Press one if you won your set.
Yeah, yeah, press one when you're set.
I didn't even lose you, bro.
Earn that one, bro.
Earn that one.
Oh my god all the blocks.
Oh nice!
Oh.
There's a lot of neutral.
Yeah.
He does not lose.
Oh let's go.
She has to break those if she's not breaking those then.
Yeah.
baby swing swing that girl five more let's go keep that
streak good
shit oh nice yeah bro is sleeping
oh she broke too she broke too i'll be able to do that too
oh nice really even more what the fuck
nice that's right there
i love that shove move from king yeah it's like it's like a
high school like back back of the high school near the
flagpole move oh rotated look no get rotated so good and I
never use it.
It basically just puts you in plus, which is up close.
It's so good.
Wow.
I mean, what a walk really.
Nice.
Whoa, what a duck.
Cup.
Oh my god.
CD added pressure makes you a better player.
He's stronger.
Yeah, you're stronger.
He said sweating, sweating, uh, key and peel Gif.
Oh yeah.
Yeah, I'm dying over here.
But you're winning!
You're winning the round robin one, the ones that don't
matter.
This is what matters.
I said this first slam.
We absolutely dominated round robin.
Who cares?
You know, that's...
What do the points even do?
Is that seating or...
Yeah, so like I guess whoever has the most points gets
better seating or whatever.
Yeah, so the way this works...
We should be able to choose our own opponents.
It's serious.
The one with the most points is to choose who wants to
fight.
Matt man against everyone.
We just keep putting in Matt.
I can beat some of the coaches.
He's just, he's just sweating and tired.
I don't think I can win, but the coaches, you're positive.
Okay.
Dude, Amaz is too random.
I can't.
I feel like if you win the most points, we should get like
one by game, where we just don't fight anybody.
I'm pretty sure that's what's going to happen that's what
happens yeah we get a buy yeah if we do well enough it's a
bracket at the end uh but there's one more round robin day
the points on friday or one more yeah yeah basically top two
teams will get like a buy okay so we got a buy last time
yeah you're in good company oh my god i haven't hit my
ceiling yet nice i mean just like how much we're dominating
you know
I don't know how pissed that guy was.
Wow.
How would that, someone in chat, my chat was like, she's a
robot.
Why does that even hurt?
And I think that's a good question.
Because she has, maybe she's programmed to feel pain.
Maybe her bar is just her being really annoyed.
Her annoyed bar.
Yeah, like, oh.
If you annoy her enough, she overheats.
of being annoyed does not come to why would you ever give
robots pain sensors that's so up taking the arms off is so
funny is that what that is off me i was like what is he
dropping on the ground they should make it so elissa
self-destructs when she gets killed oh my god i love you so
good like drop for a double ko yeah it's like a diva bomb oh
i had trouble Oh.
Okay, I saw you play Marvel Rivals.
Did you like it?
It was really fun.
I think it, like, I think, like, it feels more casual,
though, because of a third person.
I tried playing it yesterday.
I felt the same.
I think if it was, like, first person, it'd be more
competitive.
Yeah, the third-person aspect is kind of weird, though.
That's a mobile game, right?
They're trying to make it for phones, too.
I won't be surprised, because it's, like, net ease.
I played a little bit of it, and I was like, this is okay.
You know, I don't hate it.
I think it's not competitive, but more so for, like, for
fun.
I thought it was funny that, like, all the old Overwatch
players were grinding.
We're six-stacking rank and getting top 10.
Yeah, you got Sinatra and shit.
Yeah, it's dominating.
Yeah, all the Overwatch players, the old ones, are, like,
top 20 in Marvel Arrivals.
Because all they do is six-stack and bully the poor players.
We are not breaking one.
Not now, not ever.
oh wow what the fuck is that oh what the fuck what is that
move you can't even tell them to talk to coach like you are
the coach right now
shit off me those are arms yeah yeah they're her arms if you
check her 1 plus 2 she puts her head in your hands and then
you just put it back on her Like, not that, but...
He said, what?
Wait, you can put it back on her head?
Yeah, yeah, if he texts that grab, he puts it back on her.
Wait, that's so cool.
It's really funny.
Coach, show us that.
He was flabbergasted that he didn't take it.
Got it.
I thought I pressed it.
Okay, okay.
I want to see it.
Fight!
Just take it perfectly.
You got this.
Nice.
Oh, they're defensive.
I'm really good.
Oh, nice.
Oh, wow.
Oh.
Oh, my God.
Every button on the controller.
Round two.
That fucking delay too.
A buffet of options.
Oh, the jump.
Oh, my God.
Oh, shit.
prediction that's the brain destroyer yeah oh my god her
mental's gone after seeing that i mean my would be
oh wow you hit that nice she has a radar too though she's
never gonna use it she doesn't pop she would not i told you
i read her inputs i'm in her pc that's you took the internet
fuck that oh we're doing it again oh not this time no no no
no no no way the bridge oh no what is this move Oh my god.
My leg!
What the fuck kind of move was that?
You think I could do that?
Miles, get up.
Oh my god.
Oh!
Nice!
The King Street continues!
Dude, that's a pretty well-gamed dude.
Coach, good adaptation.
That was beautiful.
That's 4-1, baby.
You kept it close for content?
Nice job.
We 4-1 that shit.
Let's go.
Yes, sir.
I was like in the second game I started enjoying the
conversation maybe it's too I know you were paying attention
to the overwatch yeah I could see you like stop paying
attention in my chats just like BP question working BP oh my
god guys we all won a match that's true yeah we we Y'all won
one.
I had to win that.
I would have gotten fired.
On the king team.
Y'all wouldn't listen to you anymore if you lost.
Oh, she's in the shell of one of that.
Am I?
I mean, I'm on Fiverr.
I don't fucking know, dude.
Check the stream, I guess.
We did it, guys.
Well, we have one more left, right?
I think one more, yeah.
One more team, and then we can all fuck off.
Yeah, we're against Kaiser's team.
fiber yeah do we are they making the lobby now you see we
have time to like warm up or not they'll do a quick match
like it's not a big deal and you could join me that's
whatever all right yeah i'm gonna make them wait for me yeah
just be like um i'm fucking dokeybird chill the out while i
play yeah chill out guys
you know what i already won my one game that was my goal Now
I can coast.
Oh my god.
Guys, I won a game.
The TP.
It could be the rollback settings or whatever.
I did it.
Yeah, because they're like a setting that you're supposed to
set it to to make it so that you don't know.
What the fuck is...
Guys, I swear I'll plug me in my PC tomorrow.
I swear.
We did it!
You guys are believers, right?
You guys all believe in me?
We still have- Oh, she's saying it was three-frame rollback,
but then there's nothing you can really do about that.
That's just what it is.
Hey, man.
Guys, I promise.
It was more than three frames.
That was like, the PS4 cannot understand what's happening.
I guess it's PS5.
It felt like PS4.
Okay, I want to practice this.
Because I want to be able to do this one day.
Guys, I can only go up.
I can only go up.
I'm just telling her to switch it to standard.
I should do that too.
I should change the map.
I don't like this map.
It's too short.
Do the king bridge.
The what?
I saw it, but I don't know if you guys understand.
I don't know how that is done.
Yeah, once I got the PC plugged in, I'll be able to pull off
the King Bridge.
Thank you, promise on that.
Guys, I promise I'll plug in the PC.
It's by tomorrow.
I got, like, the first step done.
I, like, unboxed it.
Do they want us right into the next one?
Like, right now?
Are we hanging out?
I don't know.
I'm doing quick match and so some assistance.
Yeah, me too.
I'm doing quick match right now.
Who's this?
Yeah, stay warmed up, fellas.
Oh my gosh, she has five wins.
I'm fucked.
Okay.
Please, can I do that combo my coach is trying to teach me?
Please.
I'm trying to do this combo that my coach is trying to teach
me.
I don't care.
I'm in a quick match.
Please.
There you go.
No, I fucked it up!
Please, please.
I need to do this combo.
I don't care if I lose this.
do this combo.
Don't make me pull off this.
Oh, never mind.
You can just kill me.
Please.
Please, I just want to pull off this one combo.
I did it!
I pulled it off in game!
Oh my god, nothing matters anymore.
Now you die.
I Pulled it off.
Oh, shit.
No, never mind.
I thought she would keep.
Yay!
That's all I wanted.
Please.
Oh, pulled it off again!
And then...
Oh, okay, never mind.
I thought she would let me keep doing this on her.
Guys, guys, this is actually...
I need you guys to know that was the first time I've ever
pulled that copy.
combo up like actually the very first time
red mayo like now I can actually not care there had a five
win game streak there's no way there's new player oh god
please give me a down forward forward neutral please please
That's the other combo I want to learn.
Oh my god, don't make me do this on you.
Now I can focus on improving my other stuff!
Like blocking!
Because what the fuck is blocking?
There we go.
Oh.
Guys, I blocked.
Guys, I...
Guys, I fucked around.
I was trying to learn how to block Guys Oh fuck Guys okay
look Look The goal was to block Nothing else I did not need
to learn anything else It was just about learning the blocks
We lost but we learned We actually hit that combo for the
first time in the against the real player i will learn how
the true it's a fighting game not a blocking game that is
true all i wanted was to be able to hit this move that's all
i wanted and also like this this is the next goal being able
to hit this and then this next goal being able to hit that
on the real player and then oh no that's the smash okay got
that no not that no not that one day blocking is disabled in
this game all right it's okay oh no it's an Eddie oh no
death cradle next you see my coach made me remove the
keybind to do the death cradle because I kept accidentally
pressing it and it's not good.
It was not good that I kept accidentally pressing it because
it's a key charge.
So I had to unbind it because of it.
Oh, please.
Eddie, please.
Please have mercy.
Oh, goodbye.
It's very predictable.
Not for that one guy I beat.
It might be predictable for you.
But I beat that one guy.
And he still didn't learn.
Oh wait he actually blocked that.
I could have grappled him.
He's blocked.
How much?
Block.
Pay to block.
They want me to start blocking, so like, can you please?
Okay, it's okay, it's a quick play.
There's no stakes involved.
They get paid off.
This time!
Yeah!
I noticed you stop blocking me!
Oh shit, never mind.
JK.
Oh no.
Yeah.
us yeah come on come on oh shit i thought you were gonna
stay on the ground paid a block and then lose hey hey look i
did one that that two sets there goodbye i'm a one and done
get ready for the next battle thank you for blocking
I still need to learn I need to get that neutral neutral
grab correct you're never allowed to block this is how Togey
become a multi-billionaire look guys it's a hard life out
there being hunting
Yeah, you gotta make some economic decisions.
Uh, are we ready?
Hello.
What, what's our room is this?
Oh, no.
I don't know.
I've been added yet.
Oh, okay.
Cause SageM was like, oh, we have a king bear coming up.
Doki and I was like, oh shit.
Oh, yeah.
No, not yet.
Boom.
The only move I know.
And this one too.
Oh See I blocked There you go Three moves that I know you
got to learn how to block them and then the step That's
right Can she juggle that is such a good question Easy Yeah,
if I find myself losing, just grab.
The three moves that I need to know.
Do you guys think they're going to, like, analyze me and
realize I only do literally three moves?
Guys, there's no way they're going to analyze me, right?
And, like, realize that.
There's no fucking way.
If you need help, oh, yeah, I definitely need.
Of course, there's no way after Round Robin 1.
No.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my gosh.
She already learned after, like, one.
How did she know?
It's not like I've been doing that, like, this entire time.
No fucking way.
Oh, shit.
Guys, I think she learned.
It's actually crazy.
You blocked.
I'm proud of you.
Team Kaiser.
Oh, shit.
Okay, we got our match starts.
Our match is starting.
Back swing fucking demon dude.
Yeah, I know about that.
Oh shit.
Please, let me live.
She's not gonna duck.
You know how I know that?
Because she also doesn't learn.
win yeah yeah i'm kidding all right let's see uh oh who's
making the lobby they pinged us so i don't let's see are we
back on we're gonna be on the mainstream apparently yeah
okay we're gonna be on the big screen guys we're gonna be
famous has not dropped a game apparently he's nice okay then
you're gonna drop his uh cherno i think cherno solid like
yeah probably one of the best third seeds this is it you're
gonna make him regret it it'll be fine yeah but he's
probably okay so you say seeds along with Kony.
Okay.
If I lose data, I know Surno.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
He's been like a streamer for a fucking long time, hasn't
he?
He's like one of the OGs.
Is he?
I see him around Tekken streams even before the SageM thing
was even a thing.
I know he's been around for a very long time.
Because Tekken wasn't his content.
used to do like other stuff really that's sick oh codes up
stage one
here here we go
don't worry i won't leak the code guys there's a password i
will oh i almost it's okay the code is a543 guys oh my god
why would you do that to a this no it's definitely 9710 go
ahead and join up yeah yeah definitely imagine just one
digit off 9712 guys when you join the lobby the code is
right there oh yeah it is oh my god whoa really it is we're
all clowns that's how you know we're content creator brain
that's really good Everyone's like, yeah, make sure there's
a code.
Now we know that Cody was unironically like...
Yeah, that was such a move, Cody.
I'm telling the truth, bro.
I'm like, that was beast.
Come on.
That's like when I have aces, and they're like, you got
aces, and I'm like, yep.
Yeah.
I love my fans.
I want everybody to play, you know?
Let's all get in here, true.
Yeah, get all you guys join our room right now.
Doki, you can't do that.
You have more viewers than all of us come out.
You can't do that.
Wait, I want to be included?
My viewers get it.
Your viewers don't.
You have like 5,000 people in there.
It's not the same.
5,000.
You have 5,000 people watching you.
My viewers are respectable.
Guys, join my lobby right now.
I bet you don't do it.
Not respectable and are poor.
And will not come to my stream and drop a Twitch Prime or
it's your one.
Because they got no money.
They got no money.
They're not subbing to me, right?
They don't got it like that.
Hey, Kony's chat.
I also have a Twitch too.
It's our Doki brand on Twitch and you can like drop me a sub
there.
Game starting!
You gotta focus!
You're about to play!
I never focus!
It costs no money whatsoever.
Everyone just shilling her.
Everyone opening the jacket full of their potions and things
to sell in front of the viewers.
Come check out my stream!
Yo, go drop those subs!
The king here.
It's always queuing.
Double king.
The same rank.
Wait, who's higher?
He's higher than me.
Here we go.
Oh my god, he's naked.
Cobra, you're like, king.
I'm getting distracted!
He's like a kid.
We disqualified.
I'm gonna get distracted.
I saw a Charlie on this.
You saw what?
Wait, what?
Oh my god, Cobra get king up.
I'm getting distracted.
getting distracted yeah how am i supposed to focus i can't
keep looking down what's happening bro bro look at his pecs
though he's like it's fine he's held every single way how
would you know have you seen what is what's underneath there
how do you know i think it smells like don't get focused on
the map what do you mean i am focusing
I can't tell which one is you because you have clothes.
Fuck, okay, I'm not focusing anymore, guys.
This thing is naked in the middle of time square!
There are a lot of- Is this grab I've never seen it in my
life?
Oh, okay.
All right, coach, you gotta tell her.
We're gonna have to talk to the coach.
If I tell her press one or two, then she'll stop playing and
look at the controller for five seconds.
That is not true.
That is absolutely not true.
That's- So I don't want to mess you up.
Where's one?
That's the one that's how I did it.
Stop!
No, I'm actually looking at the controller!
Don't lie!
Oh my gosh!
You're just...
You're messing with my groove!
Oh my gosh, double jab combo!
You guys are messing with my groove!
No more jump!
I'm gonna be very serious.
It's a serious time?
A serious match.
No, but then if I'm serious then I'm gonna think!
Watch this.
Serious gameplay.
I'm serious.
I can't look at how beautiful.
For serious gamers.
I know it's so serious.
Please get away from me.
The spacing.
Oh my goodness.
Talk about movement.
Good bait.
Nice.
Great boy.
King gameplay.
Look at that.
I told you.
The less I focus, the better I do.
Yeah.
You guys didn't see Doki KBD just then?
I saw it.
The spacing was crazy.
Bro, I totally, that was totally intentional too.
I think?
I don't know.
I like don't think when I'm playing sometimes.
Is that noticeable?
Instinct.
That just means you're a gamer.
Oh, God.
Don't, you're jinxing me, guys.
Now I'm starting to think again.
This is bad.
Oh, she's a king.
It's like she's a king player.
Oh, my God.
But she's not that much of a...
The amount of shining with it is.
Oh, no!
It's cool, you're alive.
Oh, I'm...
Well, I'll drop the elbow on the foot.
Fight.
Oh, it's like she knows.
It's weird.
Oh, my God.
Damn.
Hit that.
Oh, no!
It's fine.
Oh, no, she does that thing that you told me about, like, my
one move.
Does she duck though?
Oh, she does.
Wait, you can do that?
What was that?
That's a misdemeanor.
Explain.
Oh, the donkey!
That's a donkey!
That hit that.
I do.
Well?
All right, run up and check this out.
Shining wizard.
It'll work.
Wait, what's shining wizard again?
The running grab.
Oh, the running grab!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
The Tomahawk.
Okay, the Tomahawk.
Where was it?
Oh!
Looking on the giant channel of all the buttons.
Oh,
she blocked.
You gotta press 1, X, or square.
I need to fucking stop doing that.
I don't know.
Guys, the more I start thinking, the worse I'm doing, I feel
like...
Look at King's nipples.
I was doing better when I was distracted.
Oh, no, good break.
Oh, okay.
That's okay.
Did I go?
Do I hit that?
That's crazy.
No, what you run?
Try, not try, not try.
All right, nice try, nice try.
Okay, I need to turn my brain off again.
He just can't be naughty.
Look at him vascular.
I can't.
It's just so distracting.
It's like all there.
Like, what if those are just a little bit lower?
okay nice oh no she did that thing that you taught me she's
like yeah she's copying my moves you can duck that remember
when she runs at you yeah yeah oh unlucky oh what the fuck
what the fuck it's like King player.
Nice.
Who would have died?
Confirmed.
Wait, did I get that?
I did.
Okay.
Did I get that too?
Oh my goodness.
The level of mind games that are being played right now.
Yeah.
That's huge.
And it hurts more because he doesn't have closing.
Yeah, that's true.
That's true.
There's no padding.
There's no padding for her.
Oh no.
Oh.
Nice Oh, what she predicted me Remember you have to do the
square.
That's your mid.
That's my The square hold square hold square right now.
Okay, you'll get out of it.
Okay, I'm holding I'm holding I'm holding I'm holding That's
what I'm talking about.
Oh good whip punish too.
Oh my god.
I did it.
Oh, oh No, she fucking punches me in the nut and it hurts.
Because I have balls now.
Oh, the 4-4 neutral 2, don't you?
I don't know if you forgot about it.
I forgot what?
4-4 neutral 2.
That low sheet keeps hitting you with.
Oh, fuck 10 strings.
We're doing strings.
Oh, my God.
You thought it was friendly.
We're doing strings.
Squire, squire, squire, squire, squire.
Oh, never mind.
It's okay.
I didn't need it.
Okay.
It's okay.
I didn't need it.
This is the best match I've ever watched in my life.
I've never seen anything better.
What the fuck?
She's been my boss.
What?
How's that legal?
It's not.
Squire, squire, squire, squire.
Squire, I did it!
I learned!
Oh my god, it's like I can learn.
Good adaptation.
Okay.
Nice.
Let's go.
She's fucking goaded.
I did it.
I beat a Tekken player.
She's been playing Tekken before I started playing Tekken.
See, you guys just need to shout the controller icons yeah
yeah just order a unique low uh shirt with a big playstation
square yeah just look it has to be upside down though so she
can look down like impact text beware she yelled square
square square we did it i got two matches in yeah oh my god
i just gotta turn off my brain yeah you just gotta become
the king yeah you have to hit the yeah yeah i hit the rage
thing yeah the rage it's reina okay he got this so sir no he
matches he matches a lot apparently well dick jab will be
your best friend dick jab into giant swing or Just back
three when he's rushing you, maybe.
Ooh.
All right, I'm going to use the bathroom break.
I bet you can pull off one set.
I believe.
Get ready for the next battle.
Did you make this picture, Kony?
I just saw.
Which one?
Oh, no.
Chatter did.
Thank you, Chatter.
This is so cool.
Oh, this shit is chugging.
Why is it laggy as fuck?
Okay, never mind.
We're good.
I think we're good.
No buttons.
Oh, my half-life, gone.
Mm-hmm.
Kitty mode, Raina.
Oh, my God.
Wow.
Come on, Super Mario King.
I'll remember that.
You have a heat phone to keep in mind.
Oops.
Nice patience.
Nice patient.
Honestly, both of you.
I was like, it's going to be a match fest, and it wasn't.
Wall coach!
Let's go!
Remember the square!
Yo, why don't these guys know how to avoid that?
Yo.
He's unstoppable.
Let's go keep the king streak alive!
Fight!
I know her strength is over.
You can hop kick that if you block it.
Nice.
Yeah.
Okay.
Good duck.
He's going to duck more than he doesn't, I think, in that
situation.
You're right.
He did.
Yeah.
Oh, nice kick.
Oh my god.
Fuck.
That's alright.
Square.
Got it.
Nice!
Oh my god, that's a professional king player.
Hell yeah.
Yeah, definitely, definitely scared of the king grab, so
that king.
what what skin is this coney it's mario i don't know i just
think he looks cool this is like 1996 yeah i'm gonna say
it's like 1990s i think he looks cool this is how i look
like summit this is me at summit you know this is yeah evo
he's got little ear holes with the hat i like the sweatpants
i think he actually spreads out but it's still cute it looks
like a tf2 scout I miss TF2 so much though.
We have TF2 at home, Marvel Rivals.
Yay!
That's true.
It's the offense.
Okay.
Typical Reyna activity.
Round two.
Fight.
Okay.
I'm gonna try to find more ways to do that.
He's not ready for it.
Apparently you see Jam and Steve said that's how Triconi
dresses.
What a hot kick.
How the fuck did that hop kick go?
One day I'll be able to do a hop kick.
Just like my coach.
Coach Kony.
Coach Kony, let's go!
He's just holying.
Honestly.
He grows a shoe, honestly.
Round 3.
Fight.
Oh, that's a... Okay.
I thought that was a low, but she did the duck too.
Hmm.
Oh my god.
Oh,
you just got to hold back there.
You just have to block.
Okay.
Wow.
Oh.
Nice.
Good duck.
Yeah.
That's fair.
She's ready now.
Okay, she's ducking all the time.
Yeah.
Now it's just hop kicks.
Okay.
he's scared yeah I mean mixture exists yeah that's it
happens it's okay we have another set combos are crazy I
hate this level man fuck okay one more set from the yeah if
you got if you lost couldn't you switch stage you can if you
pick random if you want well no you're honest fine We ball,
we ball.
Oh, what a quest, dude.
Remember, if you block him, don't launch it.
That's funny.
He's just talking.
Nice.
Fuck.
Yeah.
No, he'll duck every time now.
We know this.
Yeah.
We gotta keep Juana.
There we go.
Nice.
Press the wrong button.
Oh, nice.
Fuck, dude.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Oh my god, bro.
That was insane.
Allie kick.
Okay, good.
Oh, Jesus.
Rage.
Done deal.
Nice nut shot.
Every time she does that, I'm like, okay, that's a low
because he keeps fucking hitting.
It's going to be a mid every time.
He's doing it over and over, man.
Like, it's the same fucking thing.
What the fuck?
Dude, that didn't hit.
I keep thinking it's low like I'm going low.
She's just hitting mid.
Yeah
That okay, I tried to grab you can also rage guard if
they're being like that at the corner rage are very valid.
Oh That block Dude press there Fuck Nice
What a fucking follow-up!
That's it!
What a combo!
What a grab!
Fight!
Get into your head!
Oh!
Guard break!
What a close!
Oh, nice!
Get it all.
Get it all, man.
That was crazy.
That was weird.
I didn't mean to do that.
I didn't mean to do that parry.
I tried to do back three.
Fuck man.
Just rage out there.
Refines.
Dude!
It's literally just holding down.
You hit her?
Yeah.
Just hop kick.
I'm trying to be playing out.
I'm playing frustrated.
Yeah, that's all right.
All right, lucky I'm lucky.
This guy's just one thing.
And so he, now that you know that, you can use it for next
time oh it's just where the one with more points yeah i just
need more time like i thought i kept thinking it would
change it's just one fucking thing over and over okay all
right it's cool it's all right dokey won right or did don't
give yeah i was you forgot i won that was the most hype shit
no it was hype i just wanted to make sure you just wanted to
make sure it wasn't the fluke
where are you playing against oh i played this guy yesterday
so how didn't you win you made like i did win but i think it
was uh i think it was definitely matchup gap for him and i
think he probably is coming correct but that's okay if he
wins then uh it'll be the same story but like the other way
if he silently enters me i i will be in trouble for real you
come back one to if he hits you into it then just eat the
mix the mid heat engages the low just leads into another mix
if he dynamically enters me i think i'll be okay that's not
how it's working like that why why that's what it is dynamic
entry and silent entry yeah you're right either way i'm
getting entered well do running one plus twos into the
hunting grab or anything condition this man oh god oh my god
oh my god he's naked too don't get distracted like me shadow
the hedge oh wait i think it is his sonic is the other one
oh my god his shadow shadow last time i thought or no he was
sonic right wow he's breaking doubles oh oh we can't break
He might bring a gun.
Holy fuck.
What a kick.
Oh my.
Good crap.
Oh.
Nice block.
Oh, nice.
I'm playing autopilot.
I need to fucking lock in.
That was sloppy.
Let's go.
I think he's also autopilot.
I think he's also autopiloting a little bit.
A primitive mix up.
You can forward to one that launcher he's trying.
Oh my god.
That was close.
That was a close twin piston.
Walk in.
Round three.
Mix it up.
Nice.
Okay.
Look at that damage.
Good shit.
Nice.
I got him.
Mmm.
Let's go.
Good shit.
Oh, I'm dead.
No, put you up.
Yeah, remember that.
That's safe, right?
Oh, shit, man.
That shit is safe.
Oh, no.
Not even close.
I was looking at his health bar, or my health bar, not his.
All right.
Oh, my God.
The lock, lock, lock, lock.
Nice.
Oh my god, called it too.
It is not ready for you to take that.
He hit the whole thing!
Hell yeah.
Nice.
Oh.
I got him.
Yeah!
You don't even need the delay.
You don't even need it!
One more bro.
Let's go.
that's so who who painted that for him did he go to a clown
yeah he knows a clown what a quick punch sick oh my oh my
god oh back up he's gonna throw it out hello Perry hello
Perry this dude i'm mad okay it's fine i could have had that
round let's do it let's come on come on baby what's up
what literally passed through his body it's okay that looks
strange sorry we just want to give him a little bit just
give him one oh nice sir
oh lots of damage
oh i'm trying to get too cute man it's okay we're keeping
close for content it's cool we want to pad out the 10
minutes on the youtube video
nice what the
fuck is he doing it's such a lame fucking character oh god
i'm being salty it's ever put in rage i promise you he's not
looking for it just smash it like you don't even have to
think just mash rage art if you if you have that red health
bar i promise you it'll hit and when you get the wall you
can just do back two one into the butt for it so you don't
have to worry about the delay or anything it's still a wall
combo
that's punishable that oh nice okay
Yeah, slap him!
Juggle him!
Raven?
Nice!
Good shit.
Nice.
Save that read for the win.
Oh!
Okay.
Move fight.
Oh my god.
Don't stop that combo!
Oh my god!
Oh, they're safe!
What?
What was that?
He's not wearing shoes.
It's gonna hurt.
Who glued him to the wall?
How is the second floor ass combo?
Oh,
that wasn't into what it cooked.
Oh, nice!
Nice!
Holy shit.
Damage!
Set him into the bone!
Make the ground.
Oh shit.
Got him.
That's okay.
Nice!
What the fuck?
What was that being?
Dude, that is very disrespectful.
That was so disrespectful!
Oh my god, slime!
That is extremely disrespectful.
Let's go.
Who taught you that?
Let's fucking go.
Who taught you that and can I do it too?
Man, you're killing the vibes.
Let's fucking go.
The chat, that said, fuck you, slime.
Shift her in the chat.
Shift her in the chat over there.
On the main broadcast, too.
Let's fucking go.
I need his team's reaction to that.
Was that intentional?
That's going in the montage for real.
That's very funny.
100 yeah that's very funny i thought you fucked up an input
oh my god let's do that again get them jack they're roasting
me on commentary what that's fine how dare they they're
saying i taught you that or whatever yeah i got it up i mean
they're right they're right it was all
I can't believe you would do such a thing, bro.
What about this integrity?
Oh, that was loud.
Oh, my God.
Nice.
Clean round.
Hell yeah.
So clean.
Oh, watch.
Gonna hit the ceiling.
Oh!
Nice.
I can't believe we got this guy on our team again.
This is crazy.
Seychem's last three, run it back.
I begged for him, he begged for me.
That's how it worked out, dude.
I think Seychem just didn't want to pay for more evo trips.
He just let him inject these things.
Wow.
I want to get the cool combo.
Should I fucking farm for him?
No!
Farming for the combo!
Oh, he had a disrespect doing I'll be that I'll be the devil
on your shoulder and say yeah, do it do it do it Okay, check
this out.
This is out.
Click clip clip clip.
All right.
I'm checking I'm checking.
Oh Where is it?
Oh, oh, oh my god
Stage had two levels what oh Oh my fucking god.
Is there a third level?
Dude, that's really crazy.
It was so fucking worth it.
It was so worth it.
The content.
Holy shit.
This incapacitated her.
Oh my god.
I've never seen that.
Yeah, we play with a little spank on it.
That is insane.
Oh, laundry.
Hit the ceiling.
Nice.
Do it again.
Run it back.
This is insane.
go back to how many times i watch it the screen is just
shaking what the fuck man what do you do against this that
was hammer well that's not how it came i think this is the
most unlucky matchup for this person oh nice gunner here oh
my god oh my god they got the hit in oh my god that's 30.
nice oh someone's nervous he got hit he doesn't know what to
do you're annoying dude you're annoying that is so annoying
for a lead she's still alive though no way we're spring
kicking into chat it oh
round two round two do it again do it again do the combo yes
no way yes oh it's okay we already got one of it for the
video dude counter hit good night nice job Did he quit on
me, bro?
What the fuck?
Gift her!
It's tournament, man!
He left!
Oh no!
Why?
Because I made a read?
I told you you were playing annoying.
I said you were playing mad annoying.
You are not fun to play with.
That's fine.
Oh my god.
Did he actually leave?
That's insane.
nope he's not in the yeah he left he left that's crazy oh my
god you hit me with that i'm leaving the lobby and i'm
uninstalling i'll ask for a steam refund i'm not playing
this anymore we need a last minute replacement oh my i
didn't die he actually plugged in the round robin he said
matt man yeah what's up bro ggs man Hope to see you at Evo,
dude.
Get ready for the next- You're posting!
Bro!
Because I optimized?
What?
He's being so toxic!
Okay.
I hope to see you there.
I have to see you at Evo, bro.
I'll be- I'll be- I'll be- I'm on his side.
I'm on his side at this one.
I'll- I'll shake your hand at Evo, man.
Hope to see you there.
That chandelier should fall on people.
How can I focus after what's happened?
I feel like we should get extra points for making somebody
plug.
I mean, like, it's real low.
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
Rob Pro, focus up.
How?
Do you see what's going on?
If I can play while distracted, so can you.
Oh.
Maybe not.
Come on, you got this.
I don't know what his habits are.
I guess we'll figure them out here.
We're doing it live.
Do it live.
Hold in all.
What?
I'm telling y'all, it's just rage art, dude.
That's what I'm saying, man.
It's funny that the coaches are doing it way more than
anyone else.
Just rip it, bro.
You're right.
You're right, bro.
Fucking rip it.
You're right.
It's all about the wins.
Consider it like armor, but it also armor blows.
Oh, well.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
Oh, my God.
I'm in.
Big tummy ache.
Nice.
Oh.
This is...
Oh, my God.
Oh my god.
Bro.
Chill.
Relax.
All right, put him down.
Give him another turn.
Put him down, bro.
It's his turn.
Oh.
He picks it up.
Close credit seed.
Samuel L.
Jackson comes in.
Put that young woman down.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Dude, are you serious?
Nice!
Oh my god, he's locking it in!
You go, coach!
Second coach!
The side coach!
Go coach!
Assistant coach!
Coach B.
It's like a summer camp, you know.
Yeah, yeah.
Substitute teacher.
Nice.
Oh, good break.
Oh, this guy's playing technique.
Wait.
What the?
Surely.
Okay, I was gonna say.
Break the window!
Nice.
There's that back swing.
Uh-oh.
Oh, no.
Does he got a mega combo?
This Mike?
What?
Oh my god, he broke two windows.
Processing.
Unc processing combo.
Nice, nice, nice.
What a fucked up stage!
Oh my god.
They got nukes in the sunroom.
Oh, this is where Jack is built.
Yeah.
When would they expect it?
Dude, everything's exploding.
Where is the safety here?
I think King has four clips that are about.
Oh nice.
Oh my god.
Oh no.
Enough.
Oh.
Freaky on Susanna.
Oh the brakes.
How did you break that?
Yeah, you just pushed her off.
Oh!
That's right, keep being close for the YouTube video.
Dude, I...
So many moves.
Round four.
Fight.
Please, stop.
They're fast.
I know.
With Muhammad Ali.
The dodges, too.
Ooh!
Oh!
Okay.
Nice.
Oh my god, the damage?
Okay.
Dead?
Oh, is she dead?
Yeah.
Holy crap.
Yeah!
He's strong.
He's a platform again.
He did a four here.
Damage.
Oh.
How the fuck did that wall blast?
That's crazy.
imagine imagine oh oh no solar plexus yeah that was so close
his enlarged steroid heart finally exploded all right dude
if we sweep this one that'd be such a good cap off to the
day so no pressure on but all the pressure unfortunately i
lost you can't sweep it wait you did i was thinking that too
yeah everyone's just gonna remember the Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Everybody's just here to remember that.
No, look, we can lie.
You got your moment.
Yeah, I really did.
If we think we sweeped it, the fans will think we sweeped
it.
Creative.
We just changed the narrative.
Yeah, changed the narrative.
Only the winner's right in history, and we're winning.
Oosh!
Oh, guys.
Oh!
That's crazy.
How did she miss that?
Oh, I threw.
Ernesto?
Oh!
You threw?
What do you mean?
How did you know that was, is it 12 frame?
You're a freak.
The...
Azasena's back swing where she like evades is launch
punishment.
Oh wow.
Most back swings in the game though.
Oh my god!
Read her fucking mind!
He was ready.
Oh my god!
Oh!
Oh, let's go!
This stage, bro.
Pizza Hut manager.
Oh my god.
This is what it's like to block.
Just like a ninja.
Nice.
It is a nair, yeah.
Just pressure.
Sometimes you go wrong.
Yeah.
How was that not counter hit?
She screamed when I hit her.
She's on the Wi-Fi.
What the?
Oh, he's nice.
That was a good block, though.
Oh!
That's dumb.
Wow, he's ducking hard.
He knows.
Oh, that's close.
Oh, here we go, bro.
Oh, let's go, baby.
Wrap it up.
Nice!
Nice.
Shit.
Damn it.
That's good stuff.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
Oh my god!
Oh, so close!
Nice, nice.
Pretty good.
Good player, bro.
Good player.
Chow.
That was a toughie.
There's no 3-2 though.
Yeah, 3-2.
We won it.
We won positive on most of our matches if not yeah i'm
looking at the scoreboard i don't know if it's updated but
myk well i think they're still playing myk is first at 14.
we didn't get updated yet but we're at 12.
so if we went three two i think we're we're 15.
wait so we're first unless hide tone yeah we're first unless
hide tone sweeps wait have they finished your game yet or if
they KFM is 7, so I don't think they can hit us no matter
what.
But...
Yeah, so we're at 15.
If Hytone goes 4-1, we tie.
Oh, okay.
So we...
Hey, that's really good!
We might have won.
That's incredibly good.
Yeah.
Honestly, that's sick, especially for like...
We didn't practice as much.
Like, we got a lot to learn, bro.
Didn't you start your practice like yesterday, Kony?
Yes.
Yeah.
I played a lot in the first round, the first time.
This time, I'm like, it's day one.
It's just learning.
I'm not, you know, I took it.
I didn't take it as seriously.
Good shit, guys.
All right, let's find out what's more.
Does anyone know how well High Tone did?
I don't know.
Is he on stream?
Yeah, chat.
Stream Snipe.
How well did High Tone did?
Where's my stream snipers?
3-2?
You were saying 3-2 in my chat.
If it's 3-2, then we're first.
Yeah, we're first because we're 15.
Wow.
Was that the last one?
Yeah, that's it.
We were on stream for the last one.
Yeah.
Oh, cool.
Yeah, we won.
We won the day.
Good shit, fellas.
Yeah, we did.
We won the day.
Dude, let's fucking go.
Wow.
And if people try to download me, I'm only at 1% at my level
right now.
This is the, I'm posting the scoreboard.
I don't know.
It hasn't been updated for KFM or Tone, but it doesn't
matter.
because they can't reach us.
High tone, if he went 3-2, is 14 also.
Yeah, so, and we're 15.
Yeah, they're probably going to look at, like, match counts
after that.
Good shit, fellas.
Yeah, guys, we did it.
Okay.
Doki, very proud of you for the two W's, despite no
practice.
Good shit.
Yeah, those were electric.
I beat a red, guys.
That's a hard-to-be-king player.
I have a shifter clip.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I have a clip of him rage-quaring.
George Bush, PNG.
Sir June has hit a second wall.
I hit a second wall.
Hold on.
Oh, God, dude.
Here you go, chat.
That's fucking awesome.
Dude.
Dude, there's still 15 more seconds in the clip.
Oh my god!
Bro, he's coping so hard!
Nice.
That was good, though.
We got a rage-quick clip and everything.
That was pretty good.
I feel him, man.
I'm on his side.
Jack looks annoying as shit.
That looks obnoxious.
That one combo was ridiculous.
I don't even...
Oh, I kept...
He was coping so hard.
Wait, did CJM end?
Yeah, he did.
Oh, he just ended the stream.
That's it.
I mean, we did.
No, fucking relax.
All right.
Take a break.
That was kind of fast.
Recuperate.
All right, fellas, we won.
Good shit, everybody.
First day.
Once again, Raw Pro team on top.
Throw it back in round two.
Yeah, so I'm going to drive home and then I can watch review
some of your guys' stuff and we can talk about everything
like tomorrow or later tonight.
So we're ready for the day after.
Yeah.
I'm gonna hop in with you and get some, I need some help.
Yeah, no, and the thing is, it's very easy to identify.
It's super easy to identify the shortcomings.
You know what I mean?
I think we all have extremely easy shit to, like, I don't
know.
I trust you guys to adapt harder.
You know what I mean?
Like, I'm not, I'm confident.
You guys are sick.
I mean, Doki only needs to learn mids, does it?
Yeah, I just need to learn other combos.
And they're never expected.
And they hit the leg drop after the kick, you know?
Very simple fine-tuning for our machine.
That's all I need.
I'm so proud.
It's so good to be back, bro.
And I'm going to unpack my new PC tomorrow, so I won't lag.
Easy.
Oh, true.
We get everything.
Oh, my God.
We're going to make it.
We're going to make it to Evo.
We're going to, well, you're going to make it to Evo.
Yeah, I'm going to make it to Evo.
You can come see us, you know what I'm saying?
All right, I'm down to practice maybe late tonight, but
definitely tomorrow.
Sound good?
Yeah, yeah, tonight it'll be with the scuffed mic, but yeah,
I'm down.
He's got it fun.
All right, brother.
Take care, everybody.
I'll see you guys soon.
CGs, guys.
CGs.
Road to Evo.
Bye-bye.
Oh my god, I couldn't find the fucking hang up button just
then.
Oh my god, guys!
We did so well!
As a baby, we got first place!
I can't believe it I beat two players I beat a red That man
was 10 rings above me And I knew like two I barely knew what
combo to be fair I only knew Three moves and I beat A red
and I beat A fellow king main And she's been playing king
and tech And look far longer than me and i did it while
talking i did it while being distracted guys i wasn't
focused up i did that with no thoughts in my head it's all
about instincts and and pressing the square They can't
analyze me!
I barely have anything to analyze!
The yadding is channeled into games.
Oh my god.
I actually did not expect to win any games at all.
To be fair, I went in.
I was so nervous.
I was so scared.
I was like, well, I wasn't like scared.
I was just like, oh, I'm just going in with just to have
fun, Doki.
Just to have fun.
There's no way you're going to win any of these matches.
They're so good.
Everybody's been grounding longer than me.
And then I won two.
And I got a round of SK.
And that's all that.
Did I get two rounds?
I got two rounds off SK.
I was so happy.
I don't know if SK if she was like playing nice to me or
anything.
I don't know if she was like being nice to me in the first
two rounds.
But like I take those.
those because she has like a hundred plus hours i have like
10 to 15.
i have potential oh my god it's crazy i had a lot of fun
guys just so you guys know this is round robin one we got uh
we got like one we got first place on day one there's two
more days there's round robin two we have two more days
finals is on Sunday that's why it's not my schedule but
we're in first place we got first yeah I've been streaming
for four I this does not feel like four hours I really like
my teammates I really like slime cloning bra bra pro and
madman they're they're so fucking hype our team was totally
the vibes team because we're all just talking all the time
and I love that I love that we're not like taking it super
seriously but we're still winning even though we weren't
taking it super seriously we were still winning you know we
were yapping all the time too yeah I think my favorite part
was like eat his ass and I don't know ever who it was it was
like with a spoon I don't even know who said that the
content team yeah
grab a spoon scoop it up and then and then when i was like
they're like one and so it was like hold square i was like
square i know what square is but yeah had a great time i had
a great great time with everybody hey guys i'm gonna call it
here i hope you guys had a fun time watching as always
everyone stay hydrated posture check get up and move around
to get that blood flowing me head to bed because you deserve
it i'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye